three you're listening to the hp podcast
well
guys here we are where today we bury a
friend
no i'm kidding well okay we obviously
there's
a lot of uh best podcasts in the world a
lot of heat coming from the last episode
we did involving
our crew member a.b who first of all
before we get into i will say
i will vouch for him his character as a
very great
worker and a great guy so we do love a b
but what happened was um
a b went against the family good luck
no because you're gonna [ __ ] need it
oh my god
keemstar's wow can we hear that again
yeah what did he say good luck a b
because you're gonna [ __ ] need it
i don't think you're supposed to drop an
f-bomb this early but uh hey
what can we do about it you're going to
need it
so um this episode is brought to you by
keeps so anyway you know we did a we did
an episode
yesterday talking about the thing is
we're having this internal debate
about the whole david dobrik situation
because we had
trisha obviously has a lot to say about
him and then big nick came on and did an
interview today actually we have seth
calling in two
at one o'clock in about an hour to
discuss yeah his time with the vlog
squad and we've have been having this
internal debate because
david has been or uh david a b
has been defending david
or all you know offering this
alternative perspective on the situation
and then while we were all arguing about
it because we disagree with a b but
i thought it would be interesting to
bring the conversation on the air
because
um i think it's interesting because you
get to see the perspective of people
because there's a lot of people
obviously that
that he abe is obviously not alone in
defending
david i mean david's super popular guy
he has a ton of fans he doesn't really
get that much [ __ ]
so i thought if we're going to come here
and [ __ ] on and just like
have all this content about david we
should have
i mean if we have someone on the cast
who has an altering perspective we
should
have that discussion i mean you know
what i mean seems fair in theory right
so
anyway ab uh
anyway he attempted he attempted to
i don't know if i would say defend uh
david but
give his perspective on on matters
people were not too
keen on it let's just put that lightly
he got a lot of heat
people were getting ready to bust dude
when the
yeah so we're going to talk about that a
lot
but before that because i wanted to
lighten it up a little bit i just found
this great tick tock and you know i
don't miss an opportunity
to share something fun oh it was removed
what was it i don't even remember what
it was
wow what that's how you know wait dan
what was it we i showed it to you last
night right before
like really late and you said do you
want me to save this and i said no it's
already in my document do you remember
oh yeah
i didn't watch it it was the dr phil
clip wasn't it
no um play that though just because
because i've got nothing better what the
hell it was so
disgusting i'm gonna kill you uh it was
really late i'm having a hard time
remembering i'm sorry
let me think about it for a second was
it a gorilla glue thing
uh no although that's great too dude
there's so many gorilla glue
copycats now that we're going to talk
about later too there's the gorilla glue
yeah there's i saw two already one dude
glued it to his face because he didn't
believe it and then he goes to the er
and he's gonna have to get surgery
he's gonna have to get it surgically
removed and then there's another girl
putting
i remember go ahead it was the guy the
slurpee guy
oh man where is that it was this video
this guy was at like an am pm and he had
a whole
bucket like a whole i don't know 20
gallon bucket and he was
filling he was taking cups of slurpee
and pouring it in the bucket
and the guy who worked yeah and the guy
was like you can't sir stop you can't do
that he's like listen i'm gonna pay for
it and he would take a cup
he's like that's five cups oh my god i'm
slurping he was filling the whole depot
thing of slurpee
is awesome it kind of reminds me of you
with salsa
when we go to a mexican place when we go
to a mexican place
they give you the little tiny ones for
salsa and ethan's like no no
i need a whole cup that is true i
sometimes get a watercolor and then
you like fill them up yeah that's
disgusting i don't like being compared
why would you do that to me but i do do
that i do fill up
water cups of salsa
it's i didn't find the original video i
found
the aftermath he's in his car with the
bucket completely full of slurps yeah
i wonder why i wasn't removed yeah
that's a good question probably because
he was i don't know it was uh
there was confrontation i mean there
could have been law enforcement slurpee
theft is not taken lightly in this
country right
um all right well
ab how are you feeling i mean uh it
um you know took a lot of heat yesterday
horrible you feel horrible and short
and sure i feel horrible yeah i'm
i put together something i want to say i
don't know if i should say it now or
you we you expected heat going into
yesterday i mean we all
kind of warned you but obviously this
was beyond
what you expected right and
i guess i deserve it because the way i
phrased it was
very stupid i was very arrogant in how i
phrased it i wasn't prepared
to speak the way i wanted and yeah now
i'm getting a little worried already for
you because you say it's the way you
phrased it
because i i'm not sure it's the way you
phrased it i think it's just what you
said
right what i said well then maybe i
should read what i wanted to say
did you expect trisha to make a whole
video dedicated to you and like tick
tocks dedicate you i mean that's pretty
high level
beef right i mean i knew she'd be upset
and it was stupid to me to think that i
could defend
david without offending her oh you
actually thought you wouldn't offend her
damn bro
no i mean i i figured she'd get mad but
all right well let's break it down
because i feel like
something is i feel like we should
figure this out yes something is about
the bus
so maybe abs prepared a statement okay
oh i love that can you turn a b up a
little bit
i'm having i don't want to miss anything
here okay
b so go ahead with your statement i may
i may stop you at some points
to discuss certain issues you can take
it from there all right
bear with me because i'm being sincere
with this i want to start by saying that
i was completely wrong for the
statements i made
i believe that my intentions were pure
and rooted in doing the right thing but
i'm sure
the majority of people have done
something wrong believe that i'm sorry
to everyone who is offended sincerely
i can't tell you guys how much it hurts
knowing i left so many people down
i never meant to victim shame but
unfortunately i realized now that my
urgent actions came off that way i was
trying to play devil's advocate because
i thought it was the right thing to do
but unfortunately i didn't realize how
deep the conversation would
go and i was not educated on the
severity of what i was speaking on
i was raised by two lawyers and maybe
that's why i felt the need to take the
stands of innocent until proven guilty
i'm now trying to
so again i the
my next statement my next sentence which
was completely wrong i'm not defining my
actions
i'm just trying to understand them for
my own sake i have no right to speculate
whether someone is telling the truth or
not it was extremely arrogant to me to
insinuate that someone speaking out is
doing it for malicious reason
reasons i didn't completely believe
certain individuals based on their past
actions i knew i now realize that
this is the typical behavior of someone
who is victim shaming this is the
behavior of someone who is ruthless and
sensitive and just flat out evil
these are all the terms that you're
never thoughtful
well i i don't disagree with people who
may see me that way because of what i
said
um i am so grateful for all the
beautiful people who kindly explained to
me what was wrong with what i said
the only positive aspect of my bad take
is the fact that i'm glad that it
brought to my intention my own flaws and
hopefully it could help others be more
cautious when talking about such a
sensitive topic
the amount of nasty comments and hate
i've been getting across all my social
media is insane i've been told multiple
times to kill myself and then i should
be fired
i may deserve the backlash but deserve
it or not i'm still human
and it hurts yesterday i did something
that i've never done before which was
call my mom just just to hear a voice
because of how sad i felt
i'm not trying to make myself a victim
but rather explain how i feel
i just in closing i just want to
apologize to tricia and nick and seth
and anyone else i funded trish was right
i was
i was not there i was basing my opinion
on others in the group who still
continue to support david after years of
working with him i realize now
that this is stupid of me because again
i wasn't there
i now know that uh someone is that if
someone's going to defend the other side
it should be someone that was there not
me
i'm sorry trisha if i reopen reopened
any past trauma you have been nothing
but kind and welcoming to me personally
i was stupid to think i could defend
david without offending you trisha i
fully support you and i'm sorry for
being insensitive i know it may take
time but i'll do everything in my power
to show you that i
want nothing but good for you i'm sorry
let run down i will do better
excuse my shaky voice but i'm being
sincere
that's all wow wish we had the apology
podium out i was worthy of the uh
worthy of the great apologies of this in
the show's history
okay you got some death threats i know i
saw your instagram with private
yeah i did i felt bad i just i felt bad
like lena seeing it too like yeah a
little rough i mean usually i consider
myself to be a strong person but
when it's the fact like
last night i heard uh i don't know if
it's too personal
i heard i heard lena in the bathroom
like she was trying to hide from me but
she was tearing up
and that's that's kind of what broke me
oh lena was upset
it's really hard i know what it's like i
mean whenever ethan would go some
towards something it would be really
hard on me too and
which is why i always panic when i see
him tweet because i'm like what are you
tweeting are you
ruining my life right now those are past
days i hope yes
yeah but and there's always a little bit
of ptsd
why was lena upset ab like what was her
what was upsetting her probably i mean
i tried yeah i tried not to show her
that i was bothered
um but she's just frustrated i think
because she's like it's
everything you're not it's everything
you stand against and it's just
oh she yeah yeah you know
poorly no she's the she's an angel she
is a
an angel yeah let's talk about
so let's talk about it okay
so have you obviously you've
reconsidered your position of some of
the stuff you said yesterday
do you and you understand why people are
upset right
100
i have some points here so
like a lot of people were curious like
why are you so quick to defend david
against the first hand account of like
nick and trisha
and seth on video it's just it's odd
that you would accuse three different
people of
lying and left for lack of a better word
and you know
to favor uh david
well like i said in my mind i was
thinking that i'm trying to give another
perspective
um and again i wasn't even saying that i
stand behind all those things maybe i
should have phrased it as
well someone would argue this but again
and
i didn't say that trisha and nick were
lying i did make the mistake of saying
seth was lying but i wasn't talking
about
him coming out it was more about i
thought of it as me as looking at a fake
prank
i thought i was saying that i looked at
it saying the prank was fake but i know
now that
that was stupid but so even though you
don't outright say someone's lying
that's the implication right
right because you're saying you know
that they're not being truthful about
their account
they're you're doubting their account
right
i think people are upset because a lot
of what you're doing is kind of what
you know victim shaming is so
also another point about it is that
people
who do on the side of victim shaming
a lot of times the argument would be
like you know they're lying they're just
doing it for clout
or whatever but that is so
wrong because to come out is like
as as the victim and to complain is like
the worst thing you want to do
you you get hate as the victim because
whoever you're going out against has
their own fans and they don't want to
hear it
and so it just brings up a lot of um
you know for anyone who's been through
it there's just so many misconceptions
about it
no one would do it for the cloud like
that's not a fun thing to go through
you know it's not like ooh okay i'm
gonna gain some followers and uh
you're going through awful stuff when
you do that
and the thing is for each one of you
there's like tons of people who don't
believe them right
like more people that don't believe them
don't believe them and so
and how many fake victims are there who
really fake
abuse and just kind of like made up the
whole story they're not allowed
very very small not a lot i read a stat
i don't know how they calculated but
it's like
it's like three percent it's like a very
very small percent of people that
that are not truthful about it
which is not to say it doesn't happen
but it happens but but the
fact that three people's accounts you
know
i'm not saying to like blind blindly
believe anyone but
if anything it's more logical to believe
them to not
than to not believe them you know what i
mean if you just follow
you know it's not something it's too
serious to play the fence on you can't
just
you know exactly and insane and i
realize that now and people i
i really am grateful for the people who
were nicer in explaining it to me
as to why it was offensive and there was
also another
there was another thing you said about
like um they never said no
they didn't they they nev they were
there it was all part it was all like a
sitcom
um you know the problem with
victims of abuse is that they usually
hold a lot of guilt because they feel
like it's their fault
because it's so hard to say no or to
pull your out
self out of a situation or to know even
that you're being abused
until you're separated from the
situation so
this this is another like victim shaming
tactic is to be like
they they were there they didn't leave
the situation they never said no
that's like a huge misunderstanding
about abuse is that
is that it usually happens
in situations where it's like why didn't
they just leave
you know people say that about like
wives who are in this abusive situation
why didn't they just leave because it's
not that easy
it's complicated there's lots of
emotions involved so that is
that's a really you know hurtful point
to make when you say
you know they were all just kidding like
why why were they in the vlogs
why did they say you understand that
point yeah no i
and i didn't say that they they didn't
say no but i definitely insinuated it
which is
you know well then you did say that you
did say it
that's what you meant right so i
wouldn't
say you didn't say it i mean that's what
you meant [ __ ] you ab
right
easy treasure zach is
loving it zach are you loving this
as a friend i know as a bee's friend i
i feel really awful um because
we i mean yeah everyone makes mistakes
and
whatever i mean like did you get a lot
of pleasure and hitting that button just
now
oh tremendous yeah
texting me who's the heartthrob now
[ __ ]
that's funny no but as a joke zach
called me about
probably 20 times in the past 24 hours
because you know i've somewhat been
through this you know to not to this
extent
on the show there's no cancellation you
got cancelled for being free from being
kind of creepy
yeah and like just the amount of [ __ ]
people say to you is really
awful like just it's so hard it really
is
and you don't expect it to feel that bad
but it's like
we all just want to be accepted by
everyone and when you go
right everywhere you go there's comments
following you of people
who think you're the worst person on
earth but it passes i wanted to let
you know that it does pass but you know
what i mean like you'll be fine
you know a few days yeah i mean i
understand that it passes but it's just
it feels bad at the moment though
the topic itself is just it just hurts
because of
my background and stuff i fought for and
believe in
it's it's just yeah it's exactly against
what i've always stood for
i have a deep background in civil rights
and
yeah i've spoken out against this before
but i guess i wasn't educated enough so
i guess these conversations are good
let's make sure that we're on the same
page that's what i want to do
so you know
yeah i would be careful of playing on
that guilt because like i said the
victims often feel like it's their fault
and they feel tremendously guilty for
that
so there's another thing about you said
like it was like a sitcom and everything
was a joke
trisha had a lot to say about that
obviously
i wonder if we should we should watch
her video because she makes some really
good points
in hers in the first few minutes
yeah and like when you brought you
brought up a few points i have it here
like when you brought up like oh big
nick's mom was there and i was like and
you know when you brought that up i was
like i just didn't understand like what
was the logic
you know when you say oh big nick's mom
wasn't on the jokes but she
she really wasn't though when i watched
it and like how does that justify it
you know what i mean like i'm just
curious again that was just
my fault i'm being ill prepared i mean i
had when we
when when we talked about bringing up on
the show i said
if you guys think yeah i mean i'll i'll
do it and
when i did my i had like two pages worth
of stuff
and that was pri and we were talking
loosely friday like
you know i think someone said something
like how would his family feel and i go
yeah no i agree i go
you know his mom was there too and i
wasn't saying that that means it's okay
i'm saying that
possibly other people are complicit as
well
so yeah we watched that point but we
avoided a lot of the other stuff that
was in there so it kind of just made it
seem just like a stupid
pointless point
mm-hmm but i agree it's it doesn't
it doesn't say anything okay um
let's watch let's watch uh
let's watch trisha's thing get ready
buckle up boys she's talking fast
i knew she was pissed by the way when
she was she was talking like that was
like the fastest of her ever thought
actually i want to say before i watch
this that i was very proud of trisha
because
as far as her responses go this was
probably like her most common rational
and reasoned response to
something like this so i was very proud
of trisha
except for maybe wanting to
like kill a bee right well there's
always a little bit of you know
homicidalization
i mean you can't take that homicidal
ideation
um
450 000 views ab whoa
i feel it i feel that's crazy bro that's
like a [ __ ]
my knowledge i've never known of like uh
two audiences from two large channels
like
coming down nobody yeah but i mean maybe
i deserve it
but yeah
so this is my good i couldn't help but
note that um
this video is 21 minutes long yeah and
trisha's initial
um angry rant after the instagram versus
reality video about ethan was only 18.
so you actually
beat damn high score here yeah
i mean look me trisha our friends now to
this day look how far we've come so you
know maybe
maybe friendship is in your future i
mean i called her
a i told her she looked like a open
casket funeral
i hope so i i like trisha i really do
i'm not just saying i [ __ ] hate this
guy
he doesn't feel the same i uh
i mean i i feel like you know it
if i can say i think that it probably
really just came from
a place of lack of knowledge on this
topic and
hopefully this really is just a moment
you learn from it and you know we're all
learning yeah
we're all learning about
about this is a good experience we're
all learning
together and what i what's something i
want to point out before we continue is
that
look at her hands her hands are
soaked and toner she's in blackhand
she's done this before it's unacceptable
is that from the tanning oh yeah
knowledge
i have to imagine it's from tan
is she just like applying tanning cream
to her body or something like how does
that happen
it's i yeah it's the iodine and tanning
lotion it stains
why is she so you're more knowledgeable
on tanning
issues than that like why did the
tanning stick so much
yeah exactly why do you know exactly
pointy look because
my pre-med my pre-med background i know
about iodine
staining i know iodine's prevalent and
maybe why does it stick to the hands
because the rest of her body doesn't
look that
tan so why do why are your hands absorb
the iodine if you're so
because it's hard it's blended in better
to the rest of her body
rather than just her hands because she's
washing her hands and it's coming up
real quick just what what ela said i
agree 100
yeah i mean i'm i'm grateful that
i'm educated on now you know the worst
thing i feel like is me talking on that
and hurting so many people not knowing
i'm
glad i i know yeah because i believe you
that your intentions are good yes
and you definitely wouldn't want to be
the one that's on the
wrong side yeah saying something like
that has the
undertone of the wrong message you're
going to be with the wrong side of the
argument
you know like knowingly or not knowingly
what you may say is in these words or in
other words
saying the wrong argument which i i
don't think you want to be on so
yeah yeah worth saying for sure okay
trisha
spill it reply to the dumbass eevee from
the h3 podcast called david dobrik
debate now he's a complete ask like he's
a complete dumb ass like it's not an
[ __ ] he's a complete dumbass because
he's actually sweet in person he's just
an idiot
oh that's kind of a compliment maybe she
said you're not an [ __ ] you're just a
dumbass you're a sweet person you just
don't know anything
thoughts i agree i agree that's good
well let's close the video you know why
we need to watch
any more than that that's what i'm
saying like this is a really good
response for her
she comes outside gradually
she gets more yeah she said she talks
about how to kill him she wants to fire
him
if she sees you ever at my house she'll
quit the show
she hates my smile for some reason hate
your smile i get that a lot like on the
quartering video
like god one of the top comments is like
god damn i hate abey's condescending
smile
oh really i thought about it because i
get i get i smile because i get nervous
but
yeah i don't know something about my
smile really pisses people off
his smirk oh god
i didn't think about it i didn't think
about it brutal
41 seconds into it and actually there's
like only like two minutes before he's
talking about me and already he's like
this is like a sitcom
no dumbass two minutes [ __ ] this is my
real freaking life so let's say what
i was just noting that she just said
she's only two minutes into the video oh
yeah i do think it's worth noting that
she stopped to start recording two
minutes into the video
and already he's like thank you dan no
dumbass no [ __ ] this was my real
freaking life so let's bring up the
stuff he says we're going a little hard
on jason jason
you know he has kids to feed and all
stuff like that let's let's okay so wait
wait her sitcom point is good because
you kept bringing that up they're like
it's a sitcom it's all exaggerated and i
think trisha rightly counters that by
saying it's not a sitcom this is my real
life
and i think that's true that's kind of
what everybody says is that like
it's i think david wants people to
believe it's a sitcom
but it's not really a sitcom i think if
there were any lines they got really
blurry
and maybe maybe some stuff started out
as like oh we're just kind of
exaggerating for the fun but like
in a situation like trisha it seems like
everything got way too
blurry and obviously for everybody
obviously she ended up in a hospital
you know right she ended up breaking
down that was a really good point she
said
she's like it's not a sikkim i ended up
in the hospital that was real
yeah so right you know this sick
i agree 100 and i was wrong like i said
the point i was trying to make
and again i'm wrong was that i was
trying like i was just trying to build
an opposing view and what i was saying
was that
some of the stuff they say and some of
the characters they play is like a
sitcom like in in
it's self-aware and and again i'm just
saying what i was trying to point out
today like people have characters
and like dom for example dom is supposed
to be like a you know like a
a weed dealer and he's supposed to be
crazy or whatever but then on his normal
channel he's like oh this is
you know maybe some people play
characters i don't know but like it's
definitely
trish is not playing i mean no it
doesn't it doesn't dismiss what trisha
said she's 100 right she's 100
i think the same is true for big nick
and seth who we'll talk to later
right is that i was and you know some
one of the comments made a really good
point because you were saying of seth
that um
you were saying of seth that you think
he was in on it the whole time
and one of the comments was like the
whole point of the joke is that he's
getting this against his consent like
that's the whole
joke right is it tricking him
right which is horrible yeah it's a
stupid it's a bad joke it's a
you know fake or not it's but it is bad
but he said but that's the problem
he says it is he got
seth says that they did that to him
without his consent
yeah and it's not my place to say that
he's not telling the truth
no right
all right i was i was i was there was
other situations that i and
i believe you're the one that explained
this to me and i was saying like the
reason why i felt so confident saying
that
it's stuff that he's been a part of in
his past and you said what that's
what you're doing is you're going after
his character which is character
assassination which is typical of a
abuser and i go you're right i'm not an
abuser but a victim
you're sorry ignoring the victim right
right yeah
like he might i'm not saying he is but
he might be a horrible [ __ ] dude but
it doesn't have
anything to do with the fact that
that david did that to him right it
doesn't change the fact that jason
had no costume and made out with him
yeah and i was i was stupid like i
was handling it too lightly because
again i was not looking at it like uh
i was looking into like a fake prank and
i was like my stupid points i was
thinking was
this you know this the height difference
or whatever whatever it was
just but that stuff doesn't mean
anything because you're not
like for all i know it's like yeah
you're like how do you not know that
that's fair to think but like
when you're in the moment you just don't
know how things
play out like how many times have you
been in your life where people assume
one thing
but what actually happened was
something's totally different i mean it
happens all the time because you just
don't know all the
moving parts so to sit there and be like
oh he's six the this
jason is six two and uh corinna is like
five five
i mean obviously it's fake you can't you
can't not make that assumption
just because yeah and i realize now for
two reasons one because
it's just far too serious of a topic to
speculate on you know
and then the other is like you're
setting an example for others who want
to come out
like if you're if you're blaming someone
for something or saying it's not true
you're setting an example
a bad example for others right i
realized that
[ __ ] you baby i realize
i think it's hilarious unfortunately
it helps you know like if trisha was
here what she would what would she say
right now to a b
i [ __ ] hate this guy so much no
probably something like that
it's not that you can't speculate it's
just that
he said this is what happened so it why
are you like
there's no reason for you to go out of
your way to call him a liar you know
what i mean
it's like he came out and said they did
this to me so that's the part that i
think
100 yeah i agree yeah
all right trish go off queen and
everybody once again the main issue that
i struggled with during our thing
is him defending his best friend brandon
calvia who is 20 years younger than him
his best friend
that who was dating a minor that they
thought was completely okay and i was
exiled from the group because
i actually don't know what she's talking
about here maybe i missed
something some chapter of the whole vlog
squad thing
david both made jokes with this girl who
was a minor asking sex about brandon and
saying it's completely okay not only do
they stand by him they completely
have him in vlogs and stuff like that
amy is such an idiot then he goes on to
say well trisha also made jokes
about um wanting to like being obsessed
with david and stuff like that one yes
they were jokes
two i never no one ever said that they
were uncomfortable with it i
i oh by the way this point you made i
thought was
i didn't get it either it's like just
because they trisha made jokes about
being attracted to david doesn't mean
that jason wasn't actually trying to
hook up with tana like i just
i just was a weird way of excusing
jason's behavior
i think almost every point i made that
was the flaw in it is because when i'm
trying to present another side even if i
don't believe it i'm just trying to give
another side
at the same time i'm invalidating trisha
and that was the problem
i realized that now and i yeah
well what then it's a break already yeah
we've been doing this
already
i think it's not
but there's no logical connection i feel
like
there's no logical connection to saying
trisha
joked about wanting to have sex with
david
that has nothing to do with the fact
that
jason was trying to hook up with tana
and david was pushing them to do it do
you see my point there's no
they have nothing to do with each other
right you're trying to draw a bridge
right to like kind of like assass
to make this parallel like um do you
know what i mean ela
it's just besides the point yeah it's
beside the point there's nothing to do
with the
the fact of the matter it's like
right and that's yeah and that's where i
was i just
again it's like you said it was a
character assassination yeah exactly
like initially yeah excuse me
all right let's go
alfredo's looking at me like what the
[ __ ]
it's coming up on one so one and the ad
what is happening
all right trisha you want to do the ad
trisha
she'll be like [ __ ] you ap hey buy it
keebs [ __ ] you ap
all right gotta do an ad read brought to
you by
yeah thank you to keeps
we love keeps it helps keep your damn
hair
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are 35
that's exactly my age oh more than 50
million men in the us suffer from male
pattern baldness there are only two fda
approved medicines that can prevent hair
loss
keeps offers both both both
both both keeps offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
hey what happened to my music i was
vibing on that
a little weird did oh zach froze
okay he's back your internet the
internet
research and didn't go through that well
probably takes time we gotta run a cable
to your house and [ __ ]
be patient damn what's going on with the
internet
at our office with the like support
after
i think what is it going is there a
progress okay good
anyway keep dan goes blue can we talk
about after that read
right and elia what do you want for
dinner i'm just kidding
we're in the middle of our ad reading
ethan
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medicine
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't even have to
leave your home
i love every opportunity to not leave my
home
i'm stocked up on products to prevent me
from leaving my home
during the apollo apocalypse make sure
you're stocked up with keeps so you
never have to leave your home but you
can keep your hair
even though everyone's dead you still
want your hair to look bomb
if you're in an apocalypse and you're in
your apocalypse bonker
get keeps delivered to your apocalypse
bunker even though everybody's dead
your hair will still look bomb yeah
that's all
that's important because it's about
confidence as much as anything else
yeah thank you low-cost treatment
treatment started just ten dollars per
month and keep offers generic
versions discreet packaging and proven
results keeps has five star reviews
more than any of its competitors
prevention
is key you guys you gotta keep the hair
on your head that's why it's called
keeps before it falls out
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act
right freaking now ab starter keeps
because the hair was falling out of his
head and your hair looks pretty thick
and full
what do you think ab after one day you
need to keep up with the keeps
keep up with the keeps come on oh you're
kidding
i put i take keeps every day and look at
me
beautiful no i don't
i don't take cubes i mean obviously i
don't need it but
a lot of dudes would benefit i just
don't need it i mean what can i do they
say and they say
say you use keeps i just i don't use it
i don't need it
why would i say i need cubes i clearly
have a lot of head in my i'm
a lot of hair on my head you know what i
mean
all right ethan i'm not bragging i'm
just saying it's just a matter of fact
not trying to brag i don't care hilah
goes ethan's
hair is his favorite quality because
every read you gotta go on about how you
have
well because they tell me to say that i
take keeps but i don't
why would i take damn will you take
keeps
why dan says he will not take make good
incoming
what dan gotta make good on this ad read
incoming
we're sure why i'm doing a good read
if you're ready to take action guys
please use this link
so that i don't have to do another make
good on this
if you're ready to take action to
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash after dark to receive your
first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash after
dark
the your first month free keeps.com
after dark dan if you would have just
said you would use it maybe we wouldn't
have to do a makeup
you don't want to take you don't want to
we discussed it before the show you
don't have hair but like
yeah and that's exactly take your beanie
off show them your head
leave him alone leave brittany alone
all right just feel like i'm out here on
my own
doing keeps reads anybody zack
you're not going to lose your hair are
you uh no
you have good hair thanks so much i got
good jeans
i'm done i'm done stop the music
all right keeps everybody
so anyway where were we uh yes trisha
ripping a be a new one
uh well seth should be calling in any
moment now um oh great this is a perfect
there's a perfect uh is he is he in the
lobby
okay let's bring seth um one second to
set it up
[Music]
now ab i'm gonna mute your mic during
this segment
that's fine seth
just kidding maybe but for real please
don't say anything at me
appreciate you though seth
i don't think we can hear him seth here
can you hear me
yeah i can hear you can you hear us see
us yeah i can hear you guys
nice how are you i'm doing good how are
you
very good thank you for calling in i'm
glad to see and hear from you
absolutely it's good to be on the show
yes this is like the um
you know that documentary going clear
about scientology
yeah so our show turned into going clear
vlog squad
can you can you turn them up a bit dan
okay
seth is it possible to turn your your
mic up a little bit
um i'm not sure exactly how to do that
are you just on a laptop yeah i'm on
laptop can you pull it just a little
closer to you
okay yeah is this better yeah
better thank you so seth um
seth used to be on i don't know if you
you did a lot of videos with david
and you reached out to me via big nick
because after big nick came on i know
you have a lot of history with the vlog
squad
squad as well and you wanted to share
your story so let me just ask you
uh first seth what kind of what was your
experience like
what the vlog what maybe maybe i'll ask
you first why did you reach out wanting
to share your story
because i just feel like my story also
um
ties into a lot of other people's
experiences as well
and um you know just you know i've
already
addressed a lot of things online on my
own platform
and you know my goal is just to kind of
get the message out as much as i can and
you know communicate with as much people
as i possibly can to
educate you know an audience that you
know may be uneducated about
certain things that are happening within
the social media space
i feel that um it's very quiet hold on
dan is there no way to boost him i'm
literally maxed on everything
i have no more
oh love says it's fine it's fine on the
stream really
how could that be well that's okay if
it's just us
is everyone on stream hearing this okay
zach
is anybody yeah it sounds fine on stream
okay see how loud he was
yeah go ahead okay
so okay cool they say it's fine on
stream i don't know how that's possible
but there it is
so i know there's a few situations
that i want to ask you specifically
about
but i don't know if you want to first
tell me about your experience
on the vlog squad generally yeah
yeah i mean my experience i mean the
first thing like i really want people to
understand is like
i feel like the videos that i put out
got very misinterpreted
by a lot of people people kind of see me
as like you know attacking david or
attacking jason or attacking
you know people individuals in the blog
pod but what it really was about was me
taking credit for the actions that i was
also participating in within those
videos
so i wanted to come out and say
something to
clear my own conscience from the things
that i was doing
and i was allowing to happen within
david's content but then it also brings
up another conversation
this is also david's content he's the
one that's coming up with the ideas and
he's the one that has the power and is
asking people
to participate in certain things and
there's is a lot of pressure
you know when you're in the room and
you're the only person of your skin
color or your culture
and you're trying to represent in the
right way and you're constantly being
pressured
to do things that you might know are
wrong and you are uncomfortable with
but you know when when i first got into
the group you know i was like 22 years
old i just moved to l.a
you know i was looking for a cool group
of friends that i could kind of work
with
and collaborate with i can also be
friends and also
you know have some sort of other
interesting activities going on with and
you know that group you know they were
they were cool people when i met and i
liked what they were doing
and um you know i just started
integrating myself and then as i started
integrating myself i started being asked
over and over again to kind of
participate in in bits
that you know can can kind of come off
being very culturally insensitive
and you know i i wanted to you know
apologize mainly to
to my own community but also my family
and my friends that are the same
ethnicity that you know
you know you're talking specifically
about like racial stereotype
jokes for example i remember there was a
scene where you were at the friend's
house and then they opened a fridge and
a bunch of watermelons fallout or
something
yeah exactly and so you know yeah and a
lot of kids don't understand because
these things they seem like you know
watermelon is just
you know it's watermelon like a lot of
people like watermelon i i also
particularly
enjoy eating watermelon but there is
racially charged
um ideals that are behind you know
trying to spin in a comedic way yeah
it's obvious they're making a racial
joke yeah yeah
you know but but i feel like a lot of
kids that are like 13
14 years old that might be watching that
might not really understand and then
they think like oh okay well
when i'm with david dobrik he you know
does blackface and
watermelon tropes and all these other
things oh i can do that with my black
friend and then i'm making some
cincinnati uncomfortable with his group
of caucasian friends because
of the videos that i'm participating in
do you feel like he was pressuring you
to kind of make these black
jokes when you're around him was that
because nick for example said
i was always under the pressure to be
making like little person jokes
and the minute i said i wasn't
comfortable with that anymore then i was
kind of
uh he didn't need me anymore did you
feel that same kind of pressure
yeah that that is the pressure it's not
like you know david's sitting there and
and and honestly in this podcast i want
to be completely transparent and honest
with everything that
has happened in all these situations um
you know it's not like
david is sitting there like oh you have
to do this you don't do this you're out
the group
you know yeah of course it's kind of
like an unwritten thing where you see a
pattern of
people saying like yo i'm not i'm i'm
uncomfortable with this a bro like this
isn't really cool
that all of a sudden they just disappear
and then they're not videos anymore
yeah yeah i can imagine there's a lot
it's it's weird it's almost
there's a pattern where it's like he's
he exploiting people's vulnerabilities
to make a joke out of it and then you
know
once they start feeling uncomfortable
with it because you know
it is naturally exploitative like
uh once they feel uncomfortable with it
then he just discards them
just i don't know doesn't sit right with
me
and i can see like the
the pressure being so difficult because
you're young you want to make it and
they seem like the coolest
kids in town you know oh yeah it's
happening and it's
it looks fun and they're popular so you
want to be a part of it
of course yeah it's exciting
sorry for cutting you off but but like
people don't understand how this this
all started you know it's not like we
were this
huge social media group you know from
the jump and
everyone knew that these videos were
going to blow up and get
millions of views we were literally just
at the beginning you had to just be
someone that was just around
hanging around you know as a friend to
kind of
be involved in this circle and then it
just ends up
taking off and then all this notoriety
is gained and then you know there's
repercussions and
also you know collateral damage that
happens
and you know when that happens you know
you kind of have to go to the source
of the problem and and address it
what do you say to people say oh it's a
sitcom it's all just goofs and stuff you
know
well the thing is it's like something
like blackface right like blackface was
created
in a in a comedic sense that was the
point of
them trying to mock black people make
fun of black people hold on
sorry audio just went crazy it's being
bizarre
okay the audio is great now but you were
like blasting out of the speaker sorry
to cut you off go ahead
i wasn't yelling oh no yeah it's on our
end
but uh but yeah it's like stuff like
like blackface you know it was created
you know in
in for comedy to mock black people in a
comedic sense
so it's supposed to be used in these
sitcoms
comedy shows and things of that sort
to kind of um you know undermine
african-american people
and to mock them you know and for a lot
of black people that see blackface
it is like traumatizing because you know
our grandparents
you know this is something that isn't
very long ago you know how to go through
it and they describe
you know you come from african-american
household they describe how
you know um you know traumatizing seeing
those images could be
and then i'm in the videos participating
yeah part of it you know yeah
and is there like do you have this
bitterness kind of towards those guys
and with time past
like uh when you think about not only
like
what they put you through and how they
kind of exploited you and
made kind of turned you into the butt of
a lot of racist jokes
but more about like you were in these
videos with like millions and millions
of views like the prank videos he did
have so many views and then like
you see david is
building so much and gaining pr and uh
gaining so much from these videos and
like do you end up you i don't know what
your situation is but you probably
i don't know how much you feel like you
gained from those videos
yeah definitely and that's that's the
first thing i said like
you know like it's not like the whole
entire experience with with being in
this group is just like a
a nightmare every single day you know
some days yeah you come
and things are cool and it's just
something simple like hey i'm gonna
you know um have you guys you know do
something fun for a video and then we're
gonna film it
and then other days it does get a little
bit darker
and you know to answer your question
about like being bitter you know like i
i personally you know have like healed
myself from the situation
and have you know kind of came to terms
with everything that has happened
i'm always happy for other people's
success i think david
you know is a is genuinely at its core
you know a good person and that's kind
of why
you know his videos have have gotten so
big but just because you're a good
person doesn't mean you don't ever do
anything wrong and that's kind of the
point
that everyone's kind of bringing up like
there is collateral damage from the
situation
and this guy isn't you know the the
worst guy to ever
exist you know my situation
very light compared to some of the
racism that
you know these different actors had to
go through just to get on camera
you know so um yeah to just completely
answer the question like no i'm not
bitter about anything i'm happy that you
know they're successful
at at a point in time as a friend
because we're dealing with each other on
a personal level
it does get pretty frustrating you know
and sometimes
it's hard to hide the frustration when
you're behind the scenes trying to
communicate with someone and say hey
we need to sit down and have a
conversation hey can we talk hey can we
do this
and then you look on the internet and
then there's like a video with some
other african-american person
being utilized to basically validate
that oh we're not really doing we never
did anything wrong see we support
african-american culture because
we have another african-american person
on
you know our videos as well you know and
you notice like after you know the black
lives matter movement
kind of dies out you know it's it's like
people stop posting people stop
collaborating with african-american
influencers people don't build any
actual institutions or actually build up
other african-american creators to put
them in positions where they can
actually be in power and make choices
for themselves
you know i feel like african-american
people you know like we get this
this stereotype of like looking for
handouts and and we're not looking for
handouts we're looking
to be in actual positions of power so we
can make our own decisions
yeah are you saying that david got some
kind of like token black person after
you left
i didn't i didn't follow so i wasn't
sure exactly what you're talking about
i was talking about like the um you know
like with um
in during the black lives matter
movement how jason gets like i i forgot
the other dude's name but like king
batch and this
this um other dude who's uh who's a
youtuber you know in this youtube video
and it's like oh it's time to make a
change
you know my two black friends and you
know i could even see some of the
uncomfortability on king bats's face
when they started talking about
and you're like well where were they
when they actually had the opportunity
to not stereotype me and just use me
for my blackness yeah and where's the
conversation even behind the scenes
right right man you know like we know we
kind of did this we know this is wrong
um you know like we just you know want
to apologize for
you know putting you in this position x
y and z so that never happened there was
never a conversation like that
afterwards
no never a text call
email an assistant reaching out like
nothing so it kind of showed me like you
know
because originally you know like i say
in the first video that i made the
accountability video that
i'm not calling anyone you know these
are people i'm considering my friends
you know so like i'm not
going on here like saying like oh yeah
these guys are just racist i have like
all these like racist friends i'm just
saying that you know these people
may not understand certain aspects about
other cultures well that's really
interesting because trisha said the same
exact thing like when it went sideways
when she checked into the mental
hospital then all of a sudden it was
like
nobody talked to her anymore yeah so how
did you leave the group
how did you come to leave the group and
then when did you like stop hearing from
david
well it kind of started and this is this
was for
for multiple reasons some are being
personal but also
um a large chunk of it being related to
you know being in the vlog squad and
being in in david's content but
i decided to kind of move out the state
and move
to um atlanta because when i was in l.a
um
after kind of dealing with that video
with with jason
um like the make out video you know it's
like now millions of billions of people
kind of are misconstruing like my own
sexuality and how i feel about
participating in something that you know
he
that he didn't have my consent for um so
i end up moving to a different state to
kind of get away from it so it's not
like people coming up to me left and
right
bringing up a situation that is
legitimately traumatizing
so wow you it it was that hurtful to you
that whole thing that you
you moved out of l.a yeah
out of color he moved to atlanta yeah
wow i didn't realize that so i want okay
that's a good segue because i wanted to
ask you
about the kissing videos so
first of all like that kissing video the
first one
yeah that always struck me as so
mean-spirited and messed up
so tell me about first of all that
experience for you
how it played out and how you felt and
the reaction and everything
and what was it what was the video yeah
so it was a video where
um david set up with uh
with jason nash and karina and um
said that i was supposed to do a
make-out scene with corinna
and um had jason get into who had
was going to have karina in an old man
mass while i was making out with her
and then switched her out with jason
nash
right so my experience and my
perspective from the situation i was
literally like just getting off a flight
just got into town i was like super
exhausted from traveling
i go over to david's uh apartment well
well he calls me to come over he's like
yo can you come over like i need you for
a bit
and this is kind of like when i was you
know just starting to kind of hang out
with them so i'm just like okay david's
like asking for something that seems
pretty serious he must really need me
there
so i'm gonna go and i'm gonna you know
instead of just going home getting some
rest i'm gonna stop by his apartment and
then i'm gonna go home
and i get into the room david he's a
very convincing person he was very calm
and and everything seemed normal and he
was just like yeah you know like
we just have the scene you know like i
wanted to do i want you to like make out
with karina
and um you know like are you cool with
that and i was just like yeah no i'm
fine with making out with corinna like
that's fine i don't understand exactly
what this bits for but i'm just trying
to basically just get it over with
so i can you know go home and get some
rest and then
um you know during the video we kind of
start the makeout
starts going and then it's going on for
a decent period of time
then after jason pulls off his mask and
i realized that you know i just was
touched by someone that
you know i did not you know consent to
having their their tongue and i'm sorry
it is a little bit hard to kind of like
talk about this because like this
situation
i know a lot of people because also i'm
i'm i'm a man coming out about something
that's like a
sexual battery sexual assault type of
situation
so it's kind of hard to to um
you know a person that that is is um
you know speaking about something like
this but
basically after he took off the mask
i was um you know i i it was it was a
split decision i was like it's one or
two things like
instincts and be the angry black guy in
the room and
yelling at everyone and get physical or
whatever
that might that might entail or i can
kind of just you know go along with it
and
you know maybe i'll have some new
friends that you know will will support
me and
and my ventures moving forward and and
i i made the decision to just kind of go
along with
it not also not understanding what the
repercussions would be and also not
understanding you know how much you know
10 million people
are that's seeing something that
i'm personally not comfortable with and
and i say that not to say
i'm not comfortable with with like
homosexuality
it's just even if i was homosexual and
then they switched out the
costume for a girl that was misled
and by the way the fact that you played
along with it i just wanna
i just want to tell you that that in no
way invalidates your feelings you know
what i mean
they put you into the spot they
surprised you they did something really
um uncalled for it you know uh uncalled
for
to put it lightly i mean if that
happened to me i would be just
you you were sexually assaulted by jason
i really do think so
and so the fact that you played along
with it does not validate your feelings
at all
and it's and it's really hard and i
really want the viewers to understand
it is so incredibly tough as a man
to have to say that you were sexually
assaulted
by a man the amount of trauma that you
deal with you don't even want to explain
it to like your family and your friends
because they're even my my own family
was like looking at me like oh yeah you
probably
you probably just said that that was
that was okay you know like there's no
way some people don't believe you that's
what's so frustrating about um
the way victims are treated and
sometimes it's even their own
their own family members are not gonna
believe them it's really difficult
especially men i feel that well you know
i shouldn't say that but like
it's hard for men to get successful when
this happens it is
people are tend to be even more
distrustful of men i know women get a
lot of distrust these days when they
come out but like
yeah and it happens it does it
completely on both sides like i don't
want to take it yeah i don't want to
take away but
i know what you mean you know it's just
you know the reality of the situation is
you know it
you know like it does like affect your
confidence
as a man you know you start kind of
questioning yourself and
you know with trauma you know people are
wondering like oh why are you kind of
coming out you know
two three years later like communicating
about normal
that's that's so normal dude it takes
time to process
yeah i shut down for two years and like
people would bring it up to me in public
and then i would just
you know basically ignore it like oh
well you know at least you know like i
have
you know friends that you know are doing
cool stuff you know like that's probably
why they're
they're just trying to to bring this up
to try to like bring me down but in
reality
the situation was so traumatizing that i
was just trying to act like
it just didn't even exist yeah and
that's very common you know
and by the way the fact that it was
viewed by 10 million people compounds
you know it make i'm sure that makes a
lot more difficult
the whole world saw it too you know yeah
and it's like now it's not internal
trauma and now it's like the only way to
at this trauma is to be public about it
and to talk about it openly
to everyone so that they understand like
please if you see me in public please if
you're in my dms like
do not bring this up do not talk to me
about it
i'm trying to get peace with myself
about
being involved in something like that
and sometimes you you almost victim
blame yourself you're like well i
shouldn't have been there or
you know well i chose to have them as
friends but you know at what point is it
where
it's like well david dobrik should not
have chose to
force his man to force a of a 50
year old man to put his tongue into
another man's mouth without their
consent
man or woman honestly dude if i was just
at a friend's house and there weren't
videos involved and they pranked me like
that i'd probably
i don't know if i'd be friends with them
that's the thing that when when there
are
cameras involved you also don't want to
look bad and you want to
yeah no i'm not saying that i miss you
i'm saying that because it's like
even like even just on a friend level
that prank is so [ __ ] up
to do but does it bother you do you ask
yourself like why did he do it to me
he specifically called you you were not
you he said come over he like
they specifically thought of you for
this prank
yeah i i i have no idea why
and i i definitely have thought you know
many different reasons of
of what it could have been but you know
at this point you know with how much i
see
david and jason kind of dodging things
you know like i don't know if
jason was secretly sexually attracted to
me and wanted an
excuse to you know have a sexual act
with me without me knowing because if
they knew that i would say yes to that
why would they have not asked they knew
i would like no
don't do this and then it would never
happen
oh that's a gross thought yeah
and and any sort of like evidence you
know it's like it's like they should be
able to prove
that they had my consent there should be
a video there should be a contract there
should be some sort of paperwork
and the only thing that david has is in
the second video
um which i i feel like is is racially
charged because he has to be making out
with with
a group of gorillas in a room which is
also something that is
race driven um anyway i want to talk
actually let me let me
set up the second video because i want
to ask you about that by the way i just
before i do i want i do i did notice
when you guys were
jason got so into it it was like like
how did jason do that i just
i just was probably so messed up like
how he like
went in on it probably made it feel even
more abusive
yeah how it's like yeah then it's like
i'm hearing other things like
you know about jason you know through
certain credible sources
that you know he's he's sleeping with
you know 17 year old girls at vidcon
and you know other people that you know
have different experiences with him
where they feel like jason has been very
creepy
and touchy with them yeah that's what
trisha says about it
and then it makes me feel like okay
maybe this is like i don't know if
you're
you know like sexually turned on by
watching this video and then it can go
right now
i called david um about i think it was
sometime in uh
february or march and you know i i i
politely asked him
you know i was like i understand like
everyone makes mistakes and you know i
don't feel like you hate me
and you know all this other stuff but
you know i just i need you to
to take these videos down because they
legitimately have caused me
so much trauma i just want to try to get
away from it
and then he you know offers to to to pay
me money to keep the videos up
and then at that moment i realized like
he's not a friend and then i look
a month later and then the videos are
unlisted on his channel so people could
still watch it as long as they have the
link instead of just
writing it and taking it down so the
second one is still
up by the way yeah and the and the first
one is still up
oh that's another thing that when it is
or i watched them yesterday i didn't
have any trouble finding them on this
channel
yeah it's on an unlisted link so it's
not gonna pop up oh so it's like in a
playlist or something wait i think the
second one is public
correct me if i'm wrong guys in back but
i'm pretty sure
i could be wrong they'll look and do
that but the fact that's what big nick
said is that people
whenever david doesn't want something on
video he tries to buy them out
like instead of respecting their wishes
it's like
people say i don't want this
i don't want this out there and instead
of respecting their wishes and
understanding that it makes them
uncomfortable he turns it into a money
thing
and money is power right that's
influence he's trying to influence them
to do something they don't want to do
like especially when a friend is is
telling you
that they're dealing with legitimacy
and then your net your next motive is to
be like oh
well how much money do you want wow keep
it up it's like i don't want
money i want respect it's disrespectful
yeah i mean it's even further than that
it's like no one wants to be on a like i
i have
other things that you know are going on
in my life that are that are very
important very time sensitive
and i'm not i don't want to be in a
situation where i have to deal with
extra drama and i have to talk about
other people and and get involved in
in any sort of situation that you know
might be perceived as negative and
especially with
people that you used to really care
about a lot it hurts
very deeply to have to get on this
podcast and to have to address this
because
if anything you know me and david we
should when the fans were saying like
why don't you guys have a conversation
behind the scene i'm like exactly
why don't we have a conversation behind
the scenes david
you know because it's it's just
something that
i i don't even understand why it's it's
a thing that
that that you know he's running away
from because
we know like in the bottom of our hearts
that you know this is this is bad for
the fans this is bad for the people that
support us this is bad for my brand this
is bad for his brand this is
this isn't good for for anyone's brand
to be involved in
in something like this but once it gets
to a certain point you know it's it's
also about
everyone's mental health and that's
where why i'm on the podcast right now
speaking with you
guys is because this is almost a form of
therapy for me
to kind of cope with all the stuff that
i went through now that it's public
you know at least people kind of know
how i feel about it i could actually
openly have conversations with my family
about
it and my friends about it and i don't
have to go through every single phone
number in my contacts and like hey
i went through this experience and you
know
that's something that really disturbed
me from everyone we heard so far like
nick
same thing he feel he felt like he had
to come on here to explain himself
and it's weird to me i mean worse than
weird but it's
it's just a bad character that david
wouldn't say anything himself
also there's clearly a pattern there's
people who are
who are victims of his behavior
there's three now that we know of you
nick and trisha who have all come to him
and he just he doesn't deal with it ever
he doesn't deal with it he's got to know
that there's a
issue with the way he's doing it but
it's yeah
sure there's more people and yeah right
same
same scenario where it's like you know
like like before getting
on this podcast you know like i was i
was i was very nervous about having to
get up here
and speak about this stuff because this
isn't fun this isn't exactly
horrible to do this is this is hard this
is painful
to have to kind of get through and um
and it is um very um
very um very hurtful to have to go
through this experience
yeah i'm sad that you never got to talk
to david about it because
it's funny people blame you they say oh
he's just out for clout he's just out
here doing this to get attention but
it's like
like you said you've tried to work it
out with david
and he doesn't want to do it so he's
he's in a sense
forcing you to to discuss it in this
manner and you do deserve
the respect and the recognition that
victims of
kind of this kind of sexual assault get
you know
it's just not fair to you to dismiss you
in all those ways
yeah definitely and especially when you
have like multiple
like you know relationships with someone
because it's like you know not only in
the video
videos sorry one sec seth it's quiet
again
probably something we'd yeah zoom
go ahead i don't know what sorry
sorry to give it a moment are you sure
it's because when you turn it up it
doesn't seem to affect the audio at all
that's why i think it's zoom oh you
think zoom is adjusting dan
but dan has should have an external
okay on the street okay yeah go ahead
seth i'm sorry i cut you off
yeah no what i was saying was you know
like also you know being a person
that that's not just you know a
character in the videos like helping
you know just be a comedic uh support to
everything like i'm also behind the
scenes like legitimately setting up
his video content that is too much for
him to handle like helping him
you know with jason nash's birthday
party getting him over a hundred extras
and four hours booking two
shuttles getting um getting you know
music equipment
and also having to organize all this
stuff while i'm in atlanta
and i'm i'm i'm still dealing with like
like even if you don't respect me on a
friend level like in a business sense
like i'm someone who's who who's an
asset who's here to help who's here to
support
and in both fashions you know i i feel
like it's it's just completely
you know it is disrespectful to what i
do for you and also who i
am as a person
interesting i didn't realize you were so
deeply
involved with the logistics of
everything going on there too
yeah was he paying you at any point for
that work
yeah so at the beginning it started off
like i wasn't charging
anyone for you know helping people set
up their videos doing
doing casting for anyone's projects but
over time i started getting asked by so
many people and then
you know alex needs help picnic needs
help you know
other influencers that you know are
outside of the vlog squad are asking me
to help them set up their videos
and i'm doing it left and right and my
time is so booked that i'm like yo david
like
i need you to i need you to pay me to do
this i can't just you know i can't even
just do this for like
a a youtube plug or a shout out or
anything like that like i actually need
capital
to keep this going and then um of course
you know
he did he did compensate me but the
amount of compensation that it is
compared to what other casting
agencies charge for videos that are
created in
you know such a short span of time would
really cost thousands of dollars and i'm
only charging him
you know a few hundred hundred bucks
because i want to see his business grow
and i want to see this whole entire
group grow and i'm like well if i'm
collaborating with you guys
everything that i have that's an asset
is going to be openly available to to
all of you and you can't afford it you
can't pay for it
well then yeah maybe we could work out
some promo you can't do the promo or pay
for it okay well then just do me a favor
in the future
and that's literally how i was operating
and um
you know a lot of the different a lot of
times you know it's it's
you know like like having to you know
hassle someone about
you know four or five hundred bucks you
know when when they have millions of
dollars
it's just you know at some point you're
just like okay this this isn't worth it
even if you are a star
well so let me let me move on to the
the second video because you had this
first video where
they quote unquote prank you or jason
pretends to be
corinna and makes out with you and so a
lot of people
point to the second video as they say
well this is proof
that he was in on it and it's not that
big of a deal
because he they did a second video where
they pretended to cast you in a beef
jerky commercial
and then jason comes out as a gorilla
and makes out with you basically in the
same style they did the first one
and so and he says to you i remember
specifically
he says do i have your consent to try to
get jason to make out with you again
and so tell me about how how that video
kind of played out and how you feel
about that second video
well david was sitting there and and we
were sitting almost for like 20 minutes
and he was talking to me about he's like
yo i want to do that prank again i kept
saying like no
no i don't i don't want to have to go
through that again i don't want to deal
with
you know the repercussions of having all
these people know like
like that other video people are just
starting to forget i just want to keep
it moving
and not you know be involved in any sort
of content like that anymore
and then david kind of keeps like come
on man like you know like what
what if you know how how can i how can i
get you to to
you know want to oh sorry about that
what want
um you know get your consent for this
and what people don't understand
in that moment i never gave him my
consent
i said yeah i did notice that you're
expecting
to do something to me that i don't know
that you're getting that's all he
included from you saying no
yeah and you said what because it you're
in you're in your recounting of the
story you're saying you said no i don't
want to do it
but then all he included was that clip
of you saying
how do you expect to do something to me
that i don't know how you're going to do
and then after the cameras are off
because our reality isn't just 4 minutes
and 20 seconds i was telling him on
on the couch at the apartment david
please don't do that again
oh my god and then he just
does it again and he sets it up this
time as this commercial where collab
is involved i guess jack link's beef
jerky
was was involved in it and then also
david jason
and this time not corinna was the beef
jerky
actually involved i don't i don't know i
have no idea if if that was like if that
is that video and that's something
wouldn't that be insane if they actually
paid him to do that video
to use their brand like that i feel like
i have to assume it's not
but not what they're not involved but
at the same time i don't know their name
is still
part of it well wouldn't that be crazy
if they paid him to make that video i
mean what the yeah how would that make
you feel
yeah exactly that i mean you know i i
feel i feel like you know i feel the
same way that i feel now you know it's
it's it's just shocking
you know especially like when i seen
like like the mcn
you know uh collab like participating
and giving resources
to do something like this like they're
like like at no point in time like
you know even with with the first video
it's like jason is is the adult
in the room like someone needs to be the
person
who can speak up and be the adult and
say like yo
this isn't cool they all try the thing
is everybody's blinded by his success
and his motivation his energy
that's why it's like at a certain point
i mean
there's no one to blame but david
because this is his
operation and if he doesn't want to be
the adult in the room then he needs to
hire an adult he needs to have
someone be the adult in the room yo but
there isn't one
it's it's all his decision so it it all
comes down to being his fault
i am honestly disgusted by what you told
me about how
he only included that one clip because
even myself i
i'll have to admit i hate to admit that
when i watch
that second one i was doubtful
i thought maybe seth is in on this one
because he says from the beginning that
he consent he
he he didn't say it was like the way
that he cut it made it seem like you
were in on it
yeah it's like real fast that's crazy
that's so
dirty yeah you're not thinking about it
you're not thinking like you just
want to watch the video you're not like
oh well is this actually something that
you know could be criminal i did notice
that you never consented though yeah we
didn't know i said
i said when i watched it notice he
didn't say yes
yeah well let me ask you this this leads
me to kind of my next thought is that
did he know how badly the first video
bothered you
because why would he go to do it again
even just on a personal level as a
friend
yeah so so when i explained to him while
he was trying to get my consent with the
with the second video
you know obviously it's like it's like
how people don't see it it's like david
he's like the boss you know he's the
authority figure he's a person that's
in charge and it's like you're gonna
kind of talk to your boss a little
differently than you're gonna talk to
someone who is just your friend you know
so i was just trying to communicate with
him like
you know like i i really didn't like
that like please don't do it again
like i'm not you know interested in
being involved in any sort of content
like that i feel like it's wrong
x y and z and um you know like i
i i couldn't really approach the
situation like hey bro if you do that
again like i'm [ __ ] out you know like
or
but you had expressed like i didn't like
that
yeah and so i find it really interesting
because like
the fact that he sought out to do it
again to you
it has to be in some sense that he
he knew that you didn't like it and that
made it more entertaining to him
that he thought it was better to try to
get you again
because you were so unhappy about the
first time yeah and you see that pattern
you know someone's like oh i'm afraid of
snakes and then he comes in with a snake
oh i don't like firecrackers oh we're
about to put you in a room with a bunch
of firecrackers you know it's like
all these different things that you know
might be hey i don't like sexual assault
yeah again
yeah i mean i ironically it's proof that
he knew you didn't like it
right yeah proof that he knew that he
that
you were not down and so the second time
around
so basically you guys had this correct
me if i'm wrong you guys had this brief
conversation about it
and then how long passed before this
commercial took place
um it was about like two months
so you completely forgot about it you
didn't even you had no suspicion
no suspicion at all like the emails were
official
like i made a website and
everything so it was just like a hundred
percent i'm sitting there you know like
driving from like my grandma's house and
compton to
to be involved in all these videos kind
of you know looking for something that
could kind of be a break to kind of get
me to the next level and i'm like oh
[ __ ] i just booked a commercial like
hanging out with david and all this
other stuff this is awesome like i'm
super excited about it i'm
calling my family like hey you know like
i'm about to
get a commercial like this is good
paul like my family's like no i just
basically got sexually assaulted again
oh my god
i'm laughing because it's so [ __ ] up
it's so [ __ ] up yeah
and i i same thing you know like i
understand like you know like if
you know i understand what what people
think is comedic about it like i i get
it
no i'm not i don't think it's comedic
i'm laughing at how [ __ ] up it is
i genuinely just it's like you thought
you were getting a big break and you
ended up getting sexually assaulted like
it's just the problem so
is that like as a stunt it was really
impressive what they pulled up right
and i feel like that's part of the
problem it kind of like blurs
the bad side that comes with it but like
the bottom line of the joke is so wrong
right
is really impressive but what is the
bottom line right what is it all for
that's a great point you know
so tell me so you were they're shooting
the commercial you thought you had this
big break
did you know that it was going to be
monkeys coming out to make out with you
because you mentioned that you thought
that was racially charged
no i didn't know there was like like
they said something about like
oh yeah there's going to be like these
sexy gorillas and they're going to be
touching on you and even then i was just
like jack lynx is kind of
like what's up with them you know but
then i'm already like
in there and and and you know already
kind of spent you know a week before
preparing
and going through like this this um you
know
script and all this stuff and so i'm
just like all right well you know like
i'm i'm here like i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do what i have to do but even
that even if
it wasn't like a sexual assault and if
it was just like a video i would still
be like
yeah it seems kind of racially racially
driven for sure
you probably trust the brand though it's
a big brand these people are more aware
more sensitive
exactly and i was just like they might
cut in something else
you know a caucasian kid doing something
and then it makes makes it make more
sense or whatever you know
but um when when when i found out that
that was a video that was just for
david's content you know it definitely
made me feel like
that was very racially charged and um
you know it is what it is like
it's not a joke it's sexual assault and
so jason came out as one of the gorillas
and then started making out with you
again
yeah what was the direction like where
people was
was there like a director saying like
make out with him make out with him yeah
you can hear it and uh
yeah there's a dude there was a gaffer
there was an ep
there was a whole crew you know and
and i said that in the video i was like
you you set up a whole crew to [ __ ] up
my life you know
and so what was your feeling when jason
took off the the monkey
head the gorilla head and you realized
you had been making out with jason
again at that point i was i was just
so ridiculously shocked
like i was literally in shock i was just
like how the [ __ ] did this
just happen after i told this
not only did he sexually assault you he
ruined what
was of what you thought was a really
great moment what you thought was a
great thing happening in your life
yeah exactly and um you know then again
you know i
just you know went along with with
everything that was happening and
honestly the second time it was easier
to kind of cope with it because i
already went through it the first time
you know so i was just kind of like well
you know it is what it is
like i'm a part of this group and you
know i guess this
is this is how you know things things
are going down and
at that point i just completely shut off
and you know try to act like it didn't
exist
and i want to talk to my family about it
and and you know people don't understand
like
you deal with a situation that that's
like sexual assault
you know you you can shut down for years
and not communicate with your family
your friends
and even yourself about it and then you
get into a headspace you start becoming
a person
and building a character that's not
really you and i started being around
david and everyone in the group and i
was just like
well i really don't feel like we're
friends because i don't even feel like
i'm myself when i'm with them i feel
like i created this like
character to fit into this group because
i know that it's safe
i know exactly what you mean dude i know
exactly what you mean
so is that what ultimately led to your
you're leaving the group
and moving la was that you were just
kind of this whole dynamic
it was shortly after the second time and
then also
you know i was you know we don't we
don't make money off of these videos you
know like we're not getting ad revenue
we're not getting paid directly from
david like every once in a while you
know you might be like oh i have this
skit
you know i'm gonna pay you like two
three hundred dollars to eat a cockroach
or something like that you know like you
get
opportunities like that but we basically
have to fend for ourselves and i was
just kind of in a position where
you know i was like you know i wanted to
get away and kind of start a new life
and get a new
um you know kind of kind of reset my
brand and then when i'm when i go to
atlanta you know it's a predominantly
african-american city and
you know they're looking at all the
videos that i have with david like
well this guy isn't like for black
culture like
flat face he's over here doing all these
like you know he's basically playing a
[ __ ]
in all these videos and um you know it
made it harder for me to get support out
there but you know i fought through it
and i made sure to connect with like the
right people and kind of built
you know a small um a small um
base out in out out in atlanta
um to to try to really escape you know
this this content in these videos and
even now it's like i don't even live
in la i live in arizona um as i know
you know there's people out there that
know about you know david's content
obviously but it's not as hectic as la
where
you know i'm going to these parties with
these people that have you know millions
of followers that
you know might want to bring it up in an
instagram story and start recording me
and talking about it
[Music]
does it bother you to see like david
like
he's just like bought a 10 million
dollar house and then you're saying like
you didn't
you didn't really get compensated at all
paid for the price video
you didn't get paid at all for those
prank videos right
no yeah
yeah because by the way people like to
compare to a sitcom and sitcoms people
get [ __ ] paid well
this reminds me of like jackass a lot
right where it's like it's a group of
people
and it's like semi-real and they're all
like pranking each other all the time or
whatever but
all those dudes got paid right like they
were all part of the cash yeah it's like
how is it like a sitcom when david's the
only one getting paid
and accolades and you know it's like
another thing is like everybody gets
[ __ ] on except david it seems like too
it's easy for him you know what i mean
it's like i don't know
just bad vibes yeah and so i
want to clear clear on the second video
um because he did
set it up like as a commercial and i and
i explained to him like bro like
this is literally like i spent like a
week like doing all of this you know
setting all this up like
he did compensate my time for for for
that video
but only after you asked him like dude
you gotta pay after only after i told
him like
seriously like bro like i don't know if
i could pay my rent this month because i
was relying
on one situation to basically help me
move into a new place which is literally
what my con
was wrong and then arguing with me about
giving me the money
so were you offered money by the
advertising the fake oh yeah yeah
i was offered offered money but it's
just like it keeps getting worse and
worse
how much money did they offer to pay you
it was 2500.
they so they offered you 2 500 and then
he's like oh by the way i'm not even
paying you
yeah and then i was like bro you you ha
like
i like this isn't even just my jaw is
dropping
and by the way that's not even that much
oh he can definitely afford twenty five
hundred dollars he's very wealthy
he makes a lot he got that video had ten
million views right yeah which i'm sure
he made and if he partnered with jack
links you know he probably like fifty
to a hundred grand off yeah my jaw is on
the floor
gotta think about the amount of cost
that it takes to even make something
like that i mean that probably cost me
a thousand dollars just to set up with
the cameras
getting everything let me ask you this
how much did he end up paying you was it
the full 2500
yeah for the second video the first
video i was not compensated anything and
then all the other
vlogs i wasn't compensated i am
absolutely
flabbergasted that he tried to stiff you
out of that money
i'm just but that's just and
you know what it's humiliating to have
to go to your house after that and i
literally had to grab him and i was like
bro like
i can't walk i legit if i walk out of
here and you don't send me that money
i will literally not be able to have a
home
so i i have to have you you know
compensate me for this that is
so shocking it was because i was in a
devastated position where
you know i i was i was in between places
to live
and so i had to say you know like bro i
i need
something do you think he targeted you
because he saw you as kind of an easy
mark as someone who was vulnerable
and because you like you said you were a
little bit down and out just based on
what you're saying now
and he saw you as somebody that he could
[ __ ] with who wouldn't really push back
because they were in this desperate
situation yeah
i think it's that and then and then also
i i i am coming to really believe that
it
is also my race as well because i also
i also see how you know david you know
treated other people that were my
friends that were black you know
you know did he did he try not to pay
you at first when you asked him
yeah yeah that's what i was saying he
literally you said you need to pay me
what did he say
it's hard with zoom sometimes so oh yeah
yeah so he was he was literally walking
out of the house like after we were done
or whatever we just like we're like you
know we kind of just
me and other members talked or whatever
and then he was like okay i'm about to
get out of here so he was walking out
and i was just like i grabbed him by the
arm and i was like david like
like you have to compensate me for what
you said you were going to compensate me
for this commercial
because i literally he said no this is
right now and he was and he was just
like oh come on man like you know like
i'll tag you in the video and i was just
like
i was like i need like tag me in the
video isn't going to help me eat tonight
oh my god i and i just uh
i just discovered something because i
found the video is still on youtube but
it's unlisted
um and i was because i was curious about
the jacklinks thing i'm like does this
say like
brought to you by jack's link in the
description it doesn't but
it's does have tags of other people in
this video and seth
is like the 20th person down in the list
even though you are literally the
subject of the video i accepted some
money
he didn't he didn't tag me like that in
the video
oh my god oh my god
my jaw is on the [ __ ] floor
i mean it's not funny it's not it's
humiliating and by the way just laughing
at this
we're shocked and by the way to have to
go
and beg for money from the person who
just sexually assaulted you
it's got to feel so humiliating too
and it's even more humiliating to be on
a podcast having to say that all this
happened to me you know
like when people were in my comments
saying all these
different things about like why i'm
doing this i'm like if anything this is
hurting
me more than it's you know but it's like
i have to get through this mentally
and i know eventually people will know
what the truth is and i'm not afraid to
say everything that was true you know i
could have lied and said oh david didn't
compensate me anything or
whatever try to make him look like a
worse person than he is but
honestly you don't need to you're
telling us the truth and it
it really is even worse than we would
have thought
you don't even need to try to lie it's
it's it's so bad on so many levels
and you shouldn't be feeling ashamed
even though you know it sounds like you
are
feeling you know shame and guilt and all
this stuff you really shouldn't
but it's just
[ __ ] up really there's one other thing
i wanted to ask you about
so um
on on jason and um david's
podcast he accused you of stealing
50 000 from him to build an infinity
pool were you aware of that
yeah i i've seen that video yeah so
one that video is obviously taken down
because
it's not the true story of what actually
happened
basically the the the the the actual
story is like
it's like if i recommended you to go to
a certain pizza place
and then you go to the pizza place and
they say that they're going to give you
a pizza
and then they don't it doesn't mean that
i took the money or i stole the money
from you
it just means i gave you a bad
recommendation
that i did my research on to try to make
sure
that everything was done correctly and
and and i have like receipts of the
amount of money that was spent and one
it wasn't
wasn't over fifty thousand dollars it
was like uh
ten thousand dollars or something like
that for him to build a pool and
basically the guy
who i recommended to build the pool he
just ended up
running off and like moving it was just
one of those things like how the [ __ ]
did this happen like this is so bad you
know this guy just like ran
off and i felt really bad about it and i
talked to david about it and i was like
you know like i could reach out to some
lawyers and
you know try to see what we can do about
this situation
but you know i'm recommending people my
job is to
is to give recommendations all day and i
i give people you know 50 you know i
might recommend 50 different
individuals to another individual so
every once in a while yes we do have
bad seeds or have things that go wrong
or will have disputes and
you know sometimes i'll book you know an
extra for a video
for you know another youtuber and then
they might you know be there and then
record something that they're not
supposed to record or whatever you know
those things just kind of happen at
times especially when you're doing it at
the scale that i'm doing it at where you
have you know 50 60 different clients
that all need a service you know so in
that case it was just one thing that
kind of happened i did not profit from
any of that i don't have if i had
i don't have fifty thousand dollars i
don't i never had fifty thousand dollars
in my account
um and i i i i understand how people
kind of misconstrued that
but what david was really saying is just
like yeah i just
gave him a a poor recommendation for
something and
you know and it's very unfortunate how
it went and and if
and i did everything that i could to try
to correct it and do you think what did
you think when david put you on blast
publicly it feels like a little [ __ ]
up after everything you guys have been
through
to then put you on blast and to suggest
that you perhaps
stole 50 000 from him yeah and i didn't
know if that podcast was recent or if it
just like resurfaced
but you know obviously it's it's it's
like another
you know stab in the heart you know it's
just like bro you know how hard i work
i'm looking at the thumbnail it says the
title of this video
just to put it in comments it's not does
seth scan
seth scams david for fifty thousand
dollars and the thumbnail
is you guys standing next to each other
with the minus fifty thousand dollars
yeah yeah and it's like
it's like you can imagine how something
like that the reason why there's one of
the videos
that got up to like you know like
hundreds of thousands of views you know
and i had to
you know make sure the video was taken
down because people are googling my name
looking up you know my business
certified casting and then
they they they see a video of seth stole
50
000 like that might influence them to be
like oh well i probably shouldn't use
this service so it's like
i'm trying to get away from you and
build my thing
you're still coming at me attacking me
trying to put me down i'm just like we
didn't have to say that publicly is
like why did you especially if he's not
even being completely truthful
yeah and it's like i'm not talking about
all the the invoices
and [ __ ] that you're late on paying on
and you're a multi-millionaire and going
in on you
about how you're asking for discounts
for for [ __ ]
just because you're david dobrik you
know like i'm i'm not
i'm not always bringing up those things
you know what i'm saying but it's like
you have bad business practices too
you know and and you have things that
you do that that are wrong
and and flawed as well you know and and
i'm i'm never the type of person to be
like i'm always right like
my company is not perfect we are a
startup we're doing
everything we can we're breaking records
with
with with the amount of content that
we're getting up uploaded on the
internet through helping produce and
cast these things
and and i'm very proud of it but at the
end of the day i'm still a human being
just trying to do the best that i can do
and we have hiccups and i would prefer
the hiccups that we make aren't always
public also he's such a he has such a
large platform he's like what's the
point of
airing that dirty laundry yeah
especially after everything you guys
been through
i don't know well i'm
i'm really sorry for everything you've
been through man i mean that's really
[ __ ] up
is most [ __ ] up is that you're the
victim of this two sexual assaults
and somehow you're painted as like the
bad guy in all this
amongst like his die-hard fans you know
it's just
it's so sick dude it's just it's [ __ ]
up i'm sorry
for everything that happened to you yeah
i appreciate it
i appreciate y'all you know having me on
here and and you know i also want all
the viewers to know
too like you know i'm regardless of what
happens to you in your life regardless
of all the negative situations and
you know i know people have been through
10 times worse than than
even my case with the sexual assault or
racism
and and all of that but you have to just
continue to build something for yourself
and not stop
you know no one can stop you but you i
could have took those videos and like oh
my life's over i quit i don't want to
deal with this anymore
you know and then go into my room and
and cry myself to sleep every night but
i kept getting up i kept working i kept
grinding and i kept
doing what i have to do and now i do
have something that is an
asset i do have a brand i do have
friends and i do have a lot of people
who support me offline and online
and you have to take it upon yourself to
get that strength because
things are going to happen in your life
that you don't agree to all the time
and it might not be sexual assault it
might be something it might be
a car accident that you get you didn't
agree to get into a car accident but
if you don't fix your own car no one's
gonna fix it for you
you know and that's and that's what i'm
doing now and and
you know i i literally reached out to
david like three four days before the
podcast to just try to see if he would
answer so i could talk to him
and and and not have to go public with
with
all this stuff you know and and he's
choosing to to to not help
fix something you know i feel like it's
it's just like an infection you know
if you have like a small infection on
your leg and then you're like oh it's
just a small infection i'm not going to
deal with it and it starts getting red
you're like oh i'm not going to deal
with it eventually it's going to be like
bro you got to cut your whole leg off
you know because
now this infection is going up your
whole entire body and everything's
getting
blown out of proportion when you could
just go
to the source of what the problem is and
treat the treat the problem and then
move forward
i'm sure you know i'm sure trisha i'm
sure big nick and i'm sure
and also myself we don't want to have to
be on here
doing this and i feel very bad for you
know trisha
and also jason's wife um um
to have to have you know someone that
you know is literally inside of them and
and was intimate with them to you know
have these
different stories coming out about
sexual assault and
you know being inside of minors and all
this other stuff
and and i think that um you know it's
it's really something that they kind of
got to take the time
to look at themselves to to to really
think like
you guys are hurting a lot of people
around you that
really actually care about you i wasn't
helping david out with all of his [ __ ]
because he was david dobrik he was he
was he was just a youtube kid with a
couple hundred thousand subscribers that
was my friend
that i was trying to see get to the
point that he's at now
i wanted this to happen for him i wanted
him to be this successful
and it mattered to me if i'm a part of
that success or not
but i just want respect i don't want to
be negatively affected by your success
right right and when he when you reached
out to him a few days ago did he just
ignore you
yeah just ignored me i sent jason a text
i
texted david i called jason i called
david i already answered
no one answered damn
well i'm sorry that you had to come in
here to talk about it but i sure do
appreciate you sharing your story
and i think for whatever it's worth that
um
that i think it that it helps people
sharing your story and i think you were
very uh
very i mean you explained yourself
really well it was it was really
a privilege to listen to you tell us so
thank you for coming here and sharing it
with us
oh thank you appreciate you um having me
on the podcast and um
yeah like i said this is this is really
therapy for me like
it's very appreciated to you know have
such a big platform because
you know before i just felt like i'm i'm
screaming in a closed room about a
situation
cares about you know you know with
having you know people like yourself
trisha and and others you know that are
bringing this stuff to light you know
regardless of
what their intentions might be it's we
we all can agree
that sexual assault is wrong right yes
100 percent we can all agree that racism
and and racist ideologies are wrong so
let's just push forward
and make sure and and not hold people
in a in a state where they can't change
but we have to influence people to make
the change by
being on platforms and and speaking
about it so i i think what you guys are
doing is an
incredible public service and and it
really is helping a lot of people and it
really has helped me a lot
thank you man i really appreciate it
yeah
absolutely all right take care dude god
bless thanks for calling
god bless you as well wow
that was so that was extremely
compelling stuff he was he was i mean
seth's amazing
yeah that he sold you through all that
i cannot imagine having to go through
all that you know
it's a lot
it's it's a whole different thing
hearing it from him because like you can
tell
how traumatic it was and i can imagine
too you know like
after that first one going so viral
the second one went so viral till ah
[ __ ]
and you know i mean abe how does that
make you feel hearing the account from
him firsthand
because yesterday you said he was full
of [ __ ]
yeah no i feel horrible i wish i could
have told him you know i feel sorry and
uh
i mean yeah i mean it just goes it just
goes to i feel like it goes to show
well you know in i i'm ashamed to even
say like i thought maybe the second one
was fake too
but it just really goes to show that
that's why you should believe people
like him because
we don't know what happened he says it
wasn't consensual
we should believe him because we don't
know what it was like it's easy to just
make assumptions like
oh jason was taller or and he's
how could he be tricked into doing this
what's the people i think it's
just important to remember that he is in
the position of disadvantage
coming in and saying that it again yeah
that it was against his will that he
didn't want to do it all this stuff it's
not easy for him
so why would he do it i mean people just
don't think about it
it's easy to just say oh they're coming
out for cloud or attention or whatever
but like
the amount of [ __ ] that's not the kind
of cloud you want yeah i mean the amount
of [ __ ] that that they get is way
outweighs
any of the clout it's like do you really
get cloud for coming out people don't go
oh i'm a fan of this guy
now you know what i mean that's negative
attention you don't want that attention
so for me that that was a really
powerful
his story was very i'm kind of floored
like a lot of people
so what was really painful to hear is
just you know it's from
from his perspective also being a black
person going through all that is
just another aspect we're not even you
know
obviously we wouldn't even know but it
sounds really difficult
dude if jack link was in on that that's
that's
but he's right he's right like the fact
that his
mcn collab was in on it that jack link
was potentially you know we don't know
but
like it makes sense to use the brand
yeah it makes it makes a lot of sense
that they would be in on it
yeah i do have to eat crow a little bit
i'm still looking at this video he does
have his tag
a little bit because it's in here twice
he has like a whole list of
collaborators and sets weights down on
it
but he does have his instagram still not
at the top still down a decent amount
but
higher than that should be on the very
top
but regardless i don't think you know
it's like bro i just
but do you see how like maybe not to not
to bring but just
just to kind of so we can all take this
seriously
is that like yesterday you said he's
full of [ __ ] now obviously he didn't
hear him talk and all that so i'm i'm
not bringing that up to try to bear you
but
like we all sometimes have those
reactions and so like this guy's coming
out and sharing his story
and then there's people out there saying
oh he's full of [ __ ] like it's just
it's just so like he's already endured
so much
so much wrong doing you know sucks
it's disgusting yeah i
feel horrible i was yeah i was defending
him in the chat like i said it's not
uh he's right or wrong thing you know
it's not our place just you know
to speculate in something so serious and
i appreciate his perspective on saying
that you know
being positive after the fact you know
saying that he it was a lot to put on
him but
he moving forward
baby i know you're a good guy you know
what i mean you're not you're not a bad
guy
we love you here we're all learning
you know so god bless
god there's so many details of that
story that was just
i really think what david does is this
pattern
of finding people who are exploitable
and then pushing them to the max because
he knows he
he that they're not a threat to him in
the same way for example if he sexually
assaulted
a bigger creator let's say i went to his
house because he invited me
at once upon a time to participate in
the vlog squad and i
uh and i uh declined because i don't
like being in those situations where
you're competing for attention like they
do
so i thought you know i don't want to be
in that situation i don't like those
kinds of things
but let's say i went over there and he
did that prank to me he knows
that i i don't need him
i don't need him and i have my own
platform my own voice to
like he knows it if he does that to
someone like like
seth there's almost no chance he's going
to complain
because he needs david and he has no is
a very little platform he's like 15 000
subscribers
he cannot defend himself or share like
he said
up until this moment where he came on
the show he felt like he was just
screaming in a void because he doesn't
have a platform
or the means to speak his side and
because he's such a small
force then there's plenty of people who
are just saying oh he just wants clout
and discounting his whole story dude the
dude was sexually assaulted twice
and the videos are still on david's
channel
by the way he called him and said dude
please remove these videos
he said please remove these videos and
then he said a week
weeks later they went unlisted
i mean it took me two seconds on a
google's you know it's it was posted all
over reddit when it came out and those
links are all still live so
it's not hard what was the reaction on
reddit everybody loved it oh they just
thought it was a great
well yeah i mean it wasn't elaborate it
was very impressive
i think your point was really good about
how it's like you get caught up in how
how elaborate and well executed the
video is
and the narrative and everything that
you lose sight there's actually a victim
yeah or maybe people just assume
that it's a sitcom and they're all in on
it too
you know yeah i get i mean the more i'm
learning about this
because i've never really been a fan or
follow them or anything but the more i'm
learning about it i
i said it before but it really does kind
of remind me of the jackass dynamic
you know where they pull these elaborate
pranks on each other yeah but those guys
were hardcore they were all in on it
they're all getting paid
well yes but also they had a ton
a bunch of them got addicted to drugs
and their lives fell apart after the
fact and it's like
it's not necessarily the best thing to
model anyways but
yes they it was consensual they were all
under contract
they were going into it knowing that
that's what they're signing up for is
they're all going to do these horrible
pranks to each other or whatever
and it seems like david you know was
kind of emulating that dynamic but
while you know paying people in tags
on instagram or whatever but also
they're not actually fully consenting
like
jackets right not consenting they have
no videos
asking clearly to not consent and to not
have the video
be put up and all this stuff and he
still does it anyway right
they have no vet dude i can't
i'm blown away man i'm just blown away
and you know what's [ __ ] up is that
probably david is gonna have to confront
this now
i feel like his accounting was so
powerful
i'd be maybe david just keeps ignoring
it i don't know but
it seems like he just kept ignoring her
i wish she would just talk to the guy
it's like he said he wouldn't have to
come on the podcast and talk
i wish he would just talk to the guy the
guy who he worked for him
he helped him he did all this [ __ ] for
him
and then he just discard him like he did
big nick when he realized
the big nick was also kind of in the
same situation seth was where he's like
we can make him the butt of the dog we
can joke we can exploit him in the same
way
because he's not going to [ __ ]
complain because he's just grateful to
be here
you know
i don't know how you follow that how
long we've been going dan uh
pretty long we're at an hour 50.
geez man i goofs shift gears a little
bit
been pretty heavy episode
it is heavy sometimes it's heavy yeah
i think i just i'm really [ __ ]
[Music]
i feel like very proud of seth for sure
his story so articulately i thought that
was amazing
i didn't know what to expect honestly i
feel like it came out here
yeah like it's
it's actually way worse than i thought
you know just from watching the video
he did him so dirty too because he says
like
the second time he was like i don't want
to do this i don't want to do this and
he says how are you going to conv
how are you going to get me to consent
to something
that i don't know how you're going to do
it and then he just includes that
right because even when i watched it i
was like oh he's in on it right
man that's so [ __ ] up
i mean how does that make you feel about
david as someone who's defending it
maybe
because i feel like he's kind of playing
the fool on his audience
right yeah i know it's
i think abc's yeah i'm sorry thank you
yeah like i feel like i yeah it's
horrible i'm not i just i'm just wanting
i'm not trying to dog but i'm just
getting points i'm just going here's
what your perspective is
yeah no i think the lesson everyone
should focus on and
greater than david as well in all these
situations is that it's not your place
to speculate
you know to shame someone for coming out
or saying something
yeah [ __ ] you
trisha come on we're having a learning
moment come on
she hasn't forgiven you but she'll come
around i think she'll come around
are you going to come around trisha
i cannot his smirk okay she's still mad
you guys want to talk about the gorilla
glue lady i mean i've been kind of
invested in that story maybe it'll wrap
it up a little bit
okay what's happening so
oh ian sent me something oh what the
[ __ ] ian why would you send me this
what is this ian people have been
spamming this thing
all chat james just posted this photo
where he's pregnant can i still want to
i can show this right
do i want to talk about why about him
being
bald now oh
wait can i do you think i could show
this to you it's fine right
sister it's a lot of skin it's just a
picture of him pregnant
honestly i don't really know you know
you're the youtube master yeah i mean
it's just a lot of i mean it's an
artistic photo it's okay
video he posted on his channel too i
think it's fine
i think it's mine but the algorithm all
these bots that scan your video they see
a lot of skin and they go
[ __ ] you i mean he's saying he posted it
too
i know but this is live
it's just impressive i mean look i don't
i mean the pregnant video is fine
i i i think i think he's is that
covering
oh 24 hours being pregnant what
okay what i mean look he could be brave
i don't think he's bald though i think
the bald thing is
is total [ __ ] you want to show
photos james but
i was telling ethan before the show
because i saw it too and
i feel like if he's saying it's real
maybe it looks fake because
he has makeup on he makes up his dome
which is pretty epic
oh no wait is this a real photo of him
like what like
it's so it's so airbrushed
he looks like a and i feel like it's
just
some makeup he looks like a sex dog i
don't know
you think he shaves this yeah oh my god
he does look like a sex dog
you're right let's get glam
because he does i don't believe so much
makeup that you know you kind of
probably have to continue it to the
right it would look great it would look
wild if there was like
maybe that's why it looks so fake i
think it's fake i
mean why i mean but hey what the [ __ ] do
i know maybe it's real who cares
[Laughter]
is there any donations or comments or
anything we should read
before we move on to the gorilla glue
story
i i have a comment personally i can't
help but notice that
on the episode after free britney ela's
wearing yellow
oh no are you crying for help
so i completely didn't think about it
did somebody say either wear yellow they
said that too
oh yeah evie is not wearing yellow by
the way what does your sweater say i see
you're wearing an arabic
sweater oh it says you matter you matter
oh yeah it's that's another creator
yeah michael mars he's a
great advocate for mental health i hope
you feel better abe i'm sorry that
you're going through hard times
i i know you'll i know you'll feel
better in a few days and listen
i love you i'm not i'm i'm
support i'm here for you i don't know if
you thought i was going to fire you or
something because i know a lot of people
say i'd never crossed my mind i don't
know if you were like worried about that
that's crazy
thank you no i didn't even i didn't wear
that because of this this is he's from
my hometown that's why i was wearing it
oh yeah i thought you were like dude you
should have just
owned i mean i'm not no i'm not trying
to be like i'm spreading it you almost
did
you almost got brownie points and you
just threw it all out
you almost tried not trying to i'm
all right we love you you're very
special thank you
yeah don't bury yourself ready i'm
trying to help you
thank you love you too man
i love all you guys any comments before
we go to gorilla glue
i just want to say thank you to all you
guys for checking out me i do appreciate
it
every one of you guys means the world
yeah in case you guys are wondering aby
was in a very
tough place yesterday
i'm sorry somebody just donated five
dollars to james looking like a
bald-headed bratz doll
is any comments okay
a lot of the donations if we're kind of
you know
discussing what we've talked about it's
mostly been covered
uh ten dollars though wants to know
what's going on with gerd gaming
you know by the way three last night so
you guys missed it
you beat it did you beat the dlc
no i just beat the the last boss about
so bad about doing the dlcs
well i didn't start a new game i can
still do it okay good yeah
um i was like i just
i was like you know what i don't want to
do it because i know that i just want to
enjoy the gaming
i like to play with the audio muted and
listen to like
the radio i just or podcast or whatever
it's just going to take the fun out of
it so i was like ah [ __ ] it girl gaming
i mean
we already worked so much i was telling
you like do you really want to now also
make your
free time be work too that's like the
youtuber disease is like you want to
everything exactly but you gotta you
gotta have the you gotta set the
boundaries on yourself
so that's what i did
anything else in
um no that's about it somebody just now
said they're a huge fan of the show and
they're blacksmith
and they want to send us a gift a black
shirt i'll take a blade
sure huh wait for me
send us some blaze bro so okay
we've been following tessica that's the
gorilla glue girl
very closely she was supposed to call
into the show
we got so close to getting that
exclusive seriously
she was about to call in and then she
ghosted us
and we found out she was in the hospital
well she had to go to the er
i mean she missed our show for zach was
whatever reason
that was pissed that she did that she
ghosted us to go into the er
like who does that require selfish
selfish i love you
but uh the truth is and then we're like
oh we gotta get on the phone
so we offered her what like a thousand
bucks and then she just sent you a heart
she was
she got tmz involved she i'm sure she's
onto the big bucks now
the big gorilla dollars but you know
look
i'm not giving up i'm not doing that
well she going to come around by the
time that
everyone's over it she'd be like i'll
take that thousand dollar offer now
that's what i said yeah
let's get an exclusive with bagel boss
guys
[Laughter]
i mean like you know how i guess how
much would that prime time interview be
worth
if you wanted that prime time interview
like that day you're like go call us
from the er because tmz was at the
hospital
they were they were at the hospital they
were at the plastic surgeon when she
actually got
they were everywhere filming her they
got everything
well we offered money and she didn't
talk to us so they must have paid her
yeah
yeah those bastards get the exclusive
one but it was a big it was a big
frenzies and they had the scoop so i
don't know
yeah they probably paid her but also tmc
has a lot of weight that she's like hd
podcast whatever yeah
let's go yeah yeah yeah
right right you know as shitty as as bad
as things you can say about tmz i
have to always send them love for this
very simple fact
that they said they're the only company
ever to reach out to us and say hey we
see that you're using our videos a lot
we're going to add you to our whitelist
so we don't claim your videos
yeah and i was like wow that is so
advanced super cool i like that i like
that
they are like on the cutting edge of
creator right
right i mean that is next level create a
right
we will overcome some day
so here let's see um you guys all know
the story she put gorilla glue in her
hair
and it was just absolutely stuck so
here's a here i'm going to go down the
line because we haven't talked about in
a minute but
let's see she went to the hospital oh
she got some music on very dramatic
i was like man you could have got more
photos i was like i want to see more
damn it well
oh yeah she's in so much pain look at
her poor girl i felt so bad for her
people are being so mean like i get it
it was dumb but like god damn people are
being mean
oh yeah people are being super mean to
her well
what is that i i i felt like people
felt sorry for her for the most part
until the news came that she was
considering suing
and that's when i noticed the very
noticeable shift in tone
yeah the lawsuit is probably not a good
call
because i mean it is kind of like that
yeah everybody kind of
tons of years of the product well so
i saw in the lawsuit they say it said on
the bottle
all purpose or something like that or
said multi-purpose not all-purpose
multi-purpose
sure so she's like hair but i think it
also says that it's permanent on the
bottom
i'm pretty sure they have plenty of
warnings kind of got stuck
but so her friend her this is after i
guess the er gave her tools to try to
dissolve it
and i'm gonna try to you know for it to
not burn so much
that's why we got the wall by the way i
imagine this is during like the super
bowl i think it was
you could see her like whole family in
other room partying
really you can hear there's like lots of
people in the other room i think they're
watching the super bowl
this poor girl
or people are saying the lawsuit thing
wasn't true well
but regardless i mean my point was that
that was when
the hate started happening oh it wasn't
true well what the hell that's what
people in the chat are saying
oh well then hey i fake news people are
crazy
trying to make her the bad guy
anyway she's she's in a ton of pain and
you know
yeah she can't get it out basically she
started to go fund me by the way if you
guys want to help support
22 000 let's go jessica
for what oh she started it because she
wanted to buy wigs or something she knew
she was going to lose all of her hair
all right should donate 100 bucks dan
from our card you want me to mm-hmm okay
say
nation uh strong extreme nation strong
roger or say
say uh with love
from ethan klein and then in parentheses
uh
6.8 or whatever on wiki feet whatever i
am just put my current wikifeed score
with love from ethancline
6.8 on wikifeet yeah perfect
okay thank you writing that down thank
you so much
thank you dan thank you dan
yeah uh article yesterday gorilla glue
girl denies claims she's filing a
lawsuit against the gorilla
oh company so dude the people are so
great like people literally making this
rumor just to turn her to the bad guy
you know not to do a little reversal
here from what you were saying a minute
ago but you know who
posted that rumor to tmz they did
earlier this week tmz announced
louisiana woman hired an attorney was
thinking about taking legal action
against the adhesive company that's
interesting because they were so close
with her
right and now she's denying she said no
i've never ever said that
she said in an interview with
entertainment tonight this is why tmc is
usually pretty good with the recording i
don't know
the heck by the way just to show you how
big of a phenomenon she was like unknown
and she had 600 thousand followers on
instagram
what is she at now he's probably even
higher that was from a few days ago
oh let me look and verified and very oh
yeah she was verified is that awesome
this is the real gorilla you know in a
year from now she's gonna be like i
the gorilla girl blue hair
gorilla glue hair girl she's at uh 841
thousand
841 000 let's go
story was covered in new york times tmz
new york post
gorilla glue put out a statement they
said we're very sorry to hear about the
unfortunate incident that miss brown
experienced using
our spray adhesive on her hair we are
glad to see in a recent video that she
has received medical treatment
yeah whatever trying to cover their ass
whatever
okay so here this is when it gets kind
of more interesting and more
modern
yeah you see they get this exclusive
[ __ ] she's at a barber's house
a barber shop it kind of feels like it
may have softened up a bit
but we're gonna she's literally putting
goof off on her head
goof off as like industrial strength
adhesive removers
like that is not safe for the skin
goof it off this is pretty much a
close-up of
the ponytail they got the ponytail
holders in there so
strong awful gorilla glue does not f
around
and let it breathe a little bit is this
a goof off fad look at the can all
perfect
so she just cuts her ponytail off and
she doesn't know she's cutting it off
she doesn't no look at her she goes what
why are you cutting
listener
which is funny because the plastic
surgeon that ended up uh
actually getting it off did keep her
hair so her barber kind of [ __ ] her
that was one of the things she said
right after you can hear well i guess
we'll watch the video but she's like i
wish i had known this morning
so her barber just cut her ponytail off
without telling her
just cut her whole ponytail off that
must have taken a long time to grow that
it was pretty long
oh my god so it's like what the [ __ ] did
you do now look at her dome
like i don't know why she did that that
was not helpful
i was able to get the opponent so long
but it's still not opening and she
wanted to let it breathe
too much but i mean just a little bit
got a little open right down
so yeah she might get a little bit out
of that you want to let a little bit of
air in there
i'm not sure what's the strategy so she
this barber just
[ __ ] their [ __ ] up just getting a
little bit of air in there apparently
it's crazy this poor girl man look at
look at this look at this hello
look at that that's what the barber did
to her tmz watermark
oh yeah boy they got the exclusive
bastards damn
oh my god oh this girl is having a bad
thing look how
dude look at her hair bro it's just
it looks like [ __ ] yeah it's just
goof off so what's the
not work i'm surprised goof off didn't
work shoes
so moving on let's see gorilla glue
hairdo can't get it out even after er
visit
how much did you say to donate by the
way it's 22 000.
what no oh 100 bucks
100 bucks okay 100 bucks yeah thank you
that's right how are you what which is
like a stink
i am i don't stink what i've
no i'm not saying it's you but i also
smell is he chewing something
i think somebody smells awful i think
somebody took a fat [ __ ] down here i
think i got a chat you don't smell it
you don't smell it
sometimes the shower dries out and it
walks in like a sewage
so just run the shower okay maybe or
maybe
maybe shredder took a dump i don't know
it's [ __ ] putrid you don't smell that
this is sick i literally don't smell
anything
just as ela was saying it was like
hitting me i'm like what maybe it
doesn't reach me yet
[Music]
anyway my wife left a whopper poo
on my bed
wow that was a good perfect moment
let's see jessica hired oh so this says
she had an attorney she's denies that
that's good
check the bathroom
uh let's see i
it's that you see a dump there's a
diarrhea
see it's not me it goes you stink
there's a whopper diarrhea on the floor
there's a diarrhea yeah
right you think i smell like diarrhea
nice no i asked i was asking
did you think i could excrete that
you've done it
okay fair enough
sometimes i'll say like what is this
horrific smell and you're like that was
me
yeah so i'm just kidding you're right
sometimes sometimes you get some stinks
so anyway the the big turn comes
when a plastic surgeon in beverly hills
says i can do this i can remove this for
you
and this guy is actually a total legend
he offers to do it for free because he
feels so bad for her his name is dr
michael obang i think i'm saying that
right
it's a lengthy procedure she's flying
she flew on wednesday from louisiana to
los angeles
to get the procedure done the estimate
says it will take two to three days
to get rid of it holy crap
the doctor felt so bad he's performing
the twelve thousand five hundred dollar
procedure for free oh that's nice of him
oh here we go thank you we got the
hundred dollar donation up for tessica
where's my comment i don't see the three
three
whoa blue on wednesday whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
i accidentally opened the stream where's
my comment uh i don't think you can
leave come on oh that just goes to her
so she she's just gonna be like
what the [ __ ] the wicky feet
wait it said something about wikipedia
my donation
i didn't see the comment on there so i
wasn't sure it was mine he was able to
do it
okay anyway so oh i smell it now
there you go so here's a tmz exclusive
interview they've got the whole package
these guys
uh we are going to move on yes to uh the
woman whose hair
has captivated the nation uh right
i can't i gotta be honest the interview
is not that interesting tmz you dropped
the ball
oh we could have handled it much better
now i smell it
see okay good the chat was saying uh
ethan's got covered that's why you
couldn't smell it no i smell it
it's smelling now so she was actually
put under light
anesthesia during the procedure damn
here's a here's a video of it going down
again tmz is in the [ __ ]
in the room you know they got a package
[Music]
deal
oh look at her hair
oh man the world famous gorilla glue
girl
so here's the uh surgeon
she's sleeping man she got her under
he's going in with some tweezers
they're literally in the surgery room
yeah that's not sanitary
i don't i don't think they're opening
wounds or anything they're just true
i guess it's fine oh my goodness look at
him in there just tweezing at it
this is like the best angle or like
version of seeing just how [ __ ] it
really is
this is amazing content i haven't seen
this video actually i didn't know we had
this okay move your arm lady
so he he he describes later in the video
that he
he developed some kind of solution
concoction
yeah which i mean not that i could have
come up with it but when they said what
it was it was like oh that makes sense
that sounds like it would work
it wasn't anything that crazy you know
look at them they're doing it
i made it at home well the thing is that
it just takes a lot you have to know
what you're doing
for sure because he said it took even
him two to three days
and he was really interesting because he
even took
like a wig and put gorilla glue in it
and saw that's awesome so the guy really
did his homework to try to help this
girl
really good dude honestly for helping
out
look at this so how did they end up
fixing it
so this plastic surgeon made his own
like solution
of chemicals and tested it on a wig
with gorilla glue in it and saw that it
worked
and you can see this is like i'm loving
this i don't know why i'm just
captivated by this
footage so they're running it through
her hair right now it looks like they're
making
progress you know she's sleeping wow
they put her in anesthesia wow and he
covered the cost for everything
wow get it for free pretty legit
yeah i got the list of ingredients here
if you want go ahead read it
so it was a combination of medical grade
adhesive remover
obviously aloe vera olive oil and a dash
of acetone that's it
olive oil is always in everything right
like i said he really knows what he's
doing though you know what i mean
for sure like that girl just cut off her
opponent
i don't think she's qualified that was
so annoying
oh man but who knows maybe they would
have had to do that anyway
uh it doesn't look like it it really
doesn't look like it
wow what a procedure
man she gonna wake up and just feel like
a million bucks
or probably feel like [ __ ] actually
because her dome was just
glued to her hair for like a month
i'm still down to do this by the way
what is how long okay wait wait until
we're done
because wait till we get to the coffee
cats exactly and then we'll see if
you're down
he actually describes the procedure here
this was really interesting video this
guy's
by the way a hero dr michael obeng
the legend when my office said hey
can you can you remove a gorilla glue
from somebody's cap i said of course and
i woke up i thought it was
you know they were asking questions i
looked up the compound
okay the main active ingredient gorilla
glue you know
polyurethane and we figured out the
signs how to break it down
so i then decided you know and now we're
going to reinvent it here they're the
wheel
so we have we bought chemicals that has
components to dissolve or solvent it's
medical grade adhesive removal
that we use in the operating room the
company was very generous
to us you brought me some it sounds like
they had some kind of special product
though
he says he had to get it from the
specific company you know what i mean
like
it's not something they were here
and then the active ingredient i have
another ingredient called mgd
i had an mgd to it okay which is uh aloe
vera
and olive oil mixture okay and then we
add a little
a little um acetone a little acetone
unfortunately i don't know why gorilla
glue doesn't have a solution to it and
actually i did make a phone call to
gorilla glue
that's a really good point gorilla glue
should have a [ __ ] solution ready to
go
yeah i think lawsuit
but i never talked to them you know like
i said i have a chemistry background so
i knew that that's awesome any compound
any compound can be broken
crazy that looks scary
we stuck it here okay and then we use
hair extension so this is an extension
okay with gorilla glue okay i can spend
this all day and my kids were playing
with last night
the creepy toys
we started using it all this was matted
down
all this was matted down okay we sprayed
the first so it started untangling and i
knew we had a product
that would work surgery went well uh she
had a lot of rotation on his cap
especially the edges of her hair of her
head
because of all the chemicals that she
has put in and the hand was actually
anyway he says it you know it went well
and that she didn't have that much um
she was lucky to not have that much
damage to her wow
yeah that's amazing this one guy
stepped up nobody could help this girl
i'm kind of surprised gorilla glue
didn't have a solution already
shout out to his family big big shout
out huge shout out to his family okay so
anyway
gorilla glue girl is cured
gorilla glue yes
there's a video of her afterwards where
she's running her hands through her yeah
you're like halfway in the shot can you
get yeah deeper deeper
where's the video of her when she
afterwards and she's all good and she
says i wish they didn't cut off my
ponytail i don't see that one here
oh maybe it's here let's see
cod yeah this this one here
tmz's got the goods
[Music]
there's music playing said to mute it
but she's alive and her hair is back to
normal
yeah it looks pretty like looks pretty
fun
she's just feeling her scalp for the
first time
i can't play it because of the music but
she says i wish i wish i still have my
ponytail
honestly this length is not that bad
yeah i mean
maybe she'll get used to it and rock it
yeah we're looking on the plus side here
she doesn't look happy about it though
either
well i i know it's such a violation to
just cut your ponytail like that she
didn't say anything
at least she's like she's like i don't
hear you cutting it why do i hear you
cutting air
man
anyway so okay now gorilla glue
challenge becomes a thing no now let me
say this because youtube wants me to say
do not do the gorilla glue obviously do
not
do it i don't want anybody to do this
nobody should do this
it's dangerous it's stupid it's moronic
i'm warning you with me
i'm warning you with peace and love not
with peace and love
i will not show any i will not endorse i
will not
i will not accept this is nothing with
peace and love with peace and love no
gorilla glue challenge
is that enough for you thank you youtube
sometimes will [ __ ] you big time because
they'd be like oh you didn't explicitly
say
don't do it i do not support the gorilla
glue challenge
thank you thank you with peace and love
if you do the gorilla glue challenge you
are a [ __ ]
idiot with peace and love
so this idiot first some kind of
prankster
he thinks that she's full of [ __ ] and so
he goes i'm going to prove that she's
full of [ __ ]
great bye well here i'll just let him
please speak for peace and love do not
do this
[Music]
why is gorilla glue so strong dude they
got a killer product
they got a good brand so he just
okay so you saw that yeah interestingly
enough they just cut it right there
yeah and then the next thing you see is
him in the hospital
with the glue with a cup glued to his
face look at him
look at him and
what's even worse
what did he look like he loved that
picture oh yeah
now i feel like this is fake like what
is this picture
and then oh my god
it gets worse
he was painfully peeled off at the at
the er
martin now mark must now keep his face
covered until the skin around his mouth
heals he's been told his face could get
infected and he may
need a surgery jesus
christ and love
i don't know how this laptop's weird
like it's like i'm trying to zoom in why
is everything adjusting like i clearly
don't need this to be huge
like it's just it doesn't help zooming
in it's just ridiculous
okay there you go with peace and love do
not gorilla glue anything to your face
do not endorse zach what is your
background
you cannot say you would still do it
you would still do that for this baby
i'm sorry
this baby i'm pretty sure youtube will
ban our channel if we
televise that with peace and love yeah
zach you're crazy if you want to glue
something to your face do it on your
no no no no no no no no no peace and
love we don't condone that
we do not don't have this activity look
look how beautiful it is though like
it's just shimmering it's not that
craftsmanship looks just like i watched
just some random watch 40 bucks yes look
it's a nice watch
i thought that was the 50 shades of grey
book cover
that's funny hilarious ian
i mean it's funny i thought yeah i mean
i'm not gonna hate on it
and yet another person another person
who doesn't believe it
with peace and love donut do not oh they
removed it
with peace and love do not do this
wait i back i backed it up it should be
in there i've got it i've got it all
right thank you good job zach
zach the legend backed it up i will not
show any more gorilla glue videos if
anybody else do this
i am done i am not encouraging this i
will not show any more
this is only to show the trend do not do
this with peace
and love gorilla glue challenge is
cancelled
that being said this girl after seeing
all of that
thank you thank you says
i'm going to try it no look at this why
it's really interesting because you get
to see how it all started
right like i find it it's kind of
interesting right there on the side this
side a little bit more healthier than
this side so
you know but even still drying so she
doesn't believe
it on this side what y'all think
but it's still it's still tacky let's
see nobody's gonna care about you you
know what i mean good luck getting free
surgery
uh so that's it with peace and love do
not do the gorilla glue challenge we
will show it no more
we do not do not do it it's not safe
right just goes to show you peace and
love peace and love
zach is like one second away from doing
that
you said you do it on your eyebrows bro
rolex will do anything
that's weird
you can buy it yourself i'm sure you
have ten thousand dollars
that's not the point though it's the
story behind
it really you want the story so why do i
need to buy you the rolex then
because it it makes the story that much
better when he passes it down
someday people want me to to address
fart gate 2.0
4k 2.0 i'll address it let's watch it
zach or ian
sent me the fart gate oh another one
yeah yeah y'all ethan totally farts at
3605
and the recent prize so i watched it and
i couldn't even hear the fart
but let's see
okay so we'll start with you too so i
didn't hear a fart
i i heard what i like fart challenged i
never hear that
it's right under me saying okay okay so
we'll start with you too so i didn't
know i don't hear the fart
sounds like a dan fart
anyway the obviously edited to make it
look like i'm like guiltyly looking
listen if i farted i wouldn't pull i
would pull it off i mean you i wouldn't
act
like nothing happened okay okay so
we'll start with you too there's
something you guys need to know about me
i have excellent sphincter control
i can fart very quietly whenever i want
you got good shutter
i have good shutter speed
i'm just saying like i'm telling you if
i want to far out loud it's happening if
i want to fart quiet it's happening i
have good
shutter control as access really yeah
huh so when you're with me you just
choose to from yeah
i like the blast i mean listen i prefer
to fart loud because it's fun it's like
a fun activity
i started farting in front of theater
and he loves it he goes more
he starts laughing and he goes more and
i say i can't fart more
theodore and also
whenever i fart in front of me he
immediately looks at hila because he
knows
because every time ethan does it i'm
like no
stop and then he always looks at hila to
see her get annoyed and then he goes
more
he's not really mad it's all funny but
he's just so funny now
such a little character that's the big
thing right now everything that you do
when he likes you immediately wants
more more more
so cute well that's everything is
everything
that's a hell of a show that's it folks
that's all folks you we should tag uh
seth i don't know what
did he's i don't he wasn't really trying
to promote anything also too much of his
credit he didn't even like
it's like he had no ulterior motives to
being here but
i don't know if he wants us to link him
on anything or
what's his stuff
uh let's just we'll we'll fi or i don't
know if you want to ask him
in the description yeah definitely
i just found his instagram but it's like
his instagram i know he has a youtube
with like 15 000 subs or something
oh ian just uh and just linked it
maybe ask him first though because maybe
i don't know if he
happy holidays i don't know what he
wants you know what i mean
just ask him okay you're in touch with
him right yeah cool
um
wow that was a [ __ ] that was a quite an
episode you guys
a huge shout out to seth
and thank you ab for the apology and
everything
i appreciate you and i think you're a
great guy
thank you and i hope you feel better and
i hope people can you know
appreciate ab is obviously
i feel like abe understands what he did
and he's
he's he's serious in his in like
you know trying to learn and and stuff
from the situation so
i hope you guys can see that and
there's anything i could do to rectify
what i said gorilla glue say no more
[Laughter]
i'm kidding youtube i'm kidding nobody
do that
subreddit they said a bottle of uh
super glue gorilla glue and they said
some chapstick for abe i saw that
that's pretty funny like super glue is
malty
oh my god so much
you've been through the meat grinder
buddy it's good it all happened
yeah boy dude it's kind of you got put
on blast by trisha paytas on her main
channel
like that's kind of epic mm-hmm
i mean she's done that to me a bunch of
times you out and you out did ethan's
debut tricia sitting on the floor rant
it's an infamous video
longer you're saying it has more watches
more points more run time more points
yeah a little bit of a bigger
discrepancy in our sizes
online but i deserve it i guess
i'm just saying it's a big break for you
are you sure you don't want to watch
more of joe biden guy
joel biden i'm so obsessed with him
really you want me to watch joe biden
guys
i wish i could talk like because i can't
he goes uh
they're really good i don't know
muhammad
where the [ __ ] is it
okay here it is wait tick-tock find you
need a better title than that
i think under there was there was more
stuff
9 11. i think that's the one okay here's
our boy this is all for you dan
wake up joe biden wake up
now you're living today someday
what happened 2001 by then wake
up he said wake up
he's speaking english he's speaking
english in a lot of these
i just discovered the other day
apparently he lives somewhere like
in orange county or something like he's
nearby like we might be able to get him
as a guest
oh my god that would be so good i'd love
to ask him questions man
joe biden wake up
[Music]
yeah what are you surprised about
yeah so most of the tick tock accounts
are
our um fans that re-upload his stuff
because i think he's constantly ban
evading
wait why is he getting banned i don't
know oh because i know he has a billion
accounts is that because
there was that one video where he like
kind of
threatened joe biden's life okay
he said joe biden had two years to live
that was a prophecy that wasn't
right but it could have been oh my god
[Applause]
oh my god what are you confused about
i feel like i kind of have an idea of
who that person is in the joe biden
videos
yeah but then that same person making he
makes me
he has like his political videos and
then he has his fun videos yeah yeah
also what is this aspect ratio i've
never seen like even more narrow than
arrow
yeah how does he achieve that how do you
do that
i've never seen a video like this aspect
ratio
[Laughter]
black house white house
this message for the white house
black house black house
white house what do you mean
what's confusing bad boy trump oh
an anti-trump message buckle up couples
u.s army one nation
this is
oh was this the little edit that someone
made here oh this one [ __ ]
showed me wake up
that's from and they're opening yeah
goes gordon wake up
oh there's more yeah
[Music]
it's perfect
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was so perfect
i hope he doesn't get deleted
i think we need to get to know him what
are we saying
i'm saying i hope his channel doesn't
get deleted because that's how i'm gonna
get through my weekend i'm gonna keep
watching
it's weird there's like 20 channels of
his on tick tock
but we should try to reach out zach
because i as i
understand that he is somewhere near us
uh
okay i had heard that he had some ties
to texas i hadn't heard anything about
texas well whatever it is let's get him
on the zoom call anyway sure
in the us is close enough right stay
similar time zone
i'll do my uh recon zach's pretty good
at contacting people he is
he's he's he almost got us gorilla glue
girl he did it right
but knocking almost not quite the one
that got away right
looking almost man that expire that
offer has expired
[ __ ] i've failed you
i've let you down come on i guess a
thousand wasn't enough we should have
offered more
she's big time i got a num one i gotta
know how much tmz paid her
messages in the chat saying that we
should check david's wiki feed
oh he probably has a good score he's
with heartthrob isn't he well i
well i suspect uh the football troopers
well i'm curious what it is pre football
pre-footwork oh my god they already they
definitely already paid a visit
you guys been doing work this whole time
i don't even know
yeah wait shoe size 13 there's no way
that's true he's not he's like
shorter than me 13's like big isn't it
13 is very big yeah yeah there's no way
i wear a 13.
yeah but he's like shorter than you're
pretty tall i don't think he's that tall
yeah let's take a look oh wow he's very
generous with the feed picks
[Music]
i want to talk about feet they do look
kind of big
okay calm down hilo i'm not saying that
as a compliment
i want to smell feet
imagine wearing this outfit i mean look
with peace and love but like
okay maybe i shouldn't say anything yeah
exactly shut up ethan
idiot their merch is cool um
i have to say the the the foot soldiers
have really
um had you guys already ride i didn't
even call for war that's what i'm saying
they
really started to kind of step it up i i
don't know if you saw but i i there was
a
highly upvoted reddit post all right it
was like red alert
ethan scores dropping foot soldiers
tonight
man you guys are awesome i have like 2
000 updates
you guys are like storming the capital
and i'm like yo i didn't call for the i
didn't you guys are like taking matters
into your own hands and [ __ ]
someone said it was like 4.8 at the
start of this stream
yeah what is it oh david it was that
like i was like mine
sevens god forbid no dude you guys are
dude we have 2005
2121 foot soldiers here with the five
star ratings
we are overwhelming the forces of evil
148
yeah everybody's saying 4.8 pre-war yeah
and someone is out there like
really digging through my content for
football
every time i come on here there's more
it's really impressive
like these are obscure yeah this is from
little shredder oh yeah these people are
in deep that's from a drone
that's literally from a drone that's one
of my favorite [ __ ] h3 videos
well that is just that moment
specifically
like just from your face man you guys
are
spectacular i couldn't ask for a better
army
david dobrik wow yeah he yeah
i want to smell feet he was four point
eight four four point eight that's a
good score
yeah you know it's like when you get to
know someone
and you don't like them become less
attractive it's like that with feet
you're like uh now that i know him
that's not that great what's real great
that's what's kind of gross from being
honest
it's like hairy stubby his nails are
weird
don't you think i don't like close up of
any feats
anything so weird so gross to see it's i
agree
like this is so gross that this is
online
huge mistake david
better call seth
what a weird photo that just is online
somewhere
look at this shot bro
anyway digging deep good job soldiers
someone saved me i'm not saying to give
him a one star i would never say that
i'm just saying
here's his page
interesting all right well it's the
weekend
you know it's all unwind a little bit
take it easy be coveted safe can i have
your sandwich
maybe after the show it's done we're
done let me eat my the sandwich
not during the show okay we're wrapping
it up
thank you guys for joining us i really
do appreciate seth the stories
he shared with us was captivating him
yeah
horrific and uh super i think it was
very brave of him to come out here and
relive all that for us
so with that being said i hope you guys
all have a great weekend
and we will be back on tuesday with
frenemies as usual and hopefully trisha
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys peace and love
peace and love
okay come on pass it over here i wasn't
necessarily not gonna eat it
you weren't gonna eat it it's been like
sitting there the whole show because i
don't eat during the show yeah
eat with me
[Music]
we'll do the real raw ritual with more
and e.t
share a laugh with the ringer see how
low jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
you're watching h2333 you're watching it